welcome back to the stronger by science
podcast this episode has some new
segments including the airing of
grievances in which I briefly complain
about stuff then we have feats of
strength in which we highlight some very
impressive recent lifts and also pay
tribute to a legend that passed away
last week in the main part of today's
show we have a coach's corner segment
about metabolic adaptations to weight
loss followed by question of the day
which is a new segment in which Greg and
I discussed things that we've changed
our minds about throughout our careers
plus if you only come here for the food
content Greg is going to teach us how to
make some stoop finally we interview Lee
Peele who tells us about the early days
of the evidence-based fitness movement
weight loss and metabolic adaptation as
always thank you for listening enjoy the
show
[Music]
all right welcome back to the stronger
by science podcast this is your host
Eric Trexler and before we get into the
content today sometimes people make
mistakes when you make a mistake you got
to own up in the last episode I failed
to introduce Greg as my temporary
co-host and there been a lot of rumors
swirling on the internet that maybe he's
been offered a full-time position I just
want to nip those in the bud and kind of
address those head-on that was a mistake
on my end I should have been more clear
Greg is certainly not not at all what
you'd consider a permanent co-host so
hopefully those rumors you know we'll
just put an end to those and for now
we're going to keep them temporary we're
doing the best with what we've got so
with that being said I am lobbying to be
a full-time co-host so if you would be
interested in me staying on as the
co-host of the stronger by science
podcast it would behoove everyone
listening to this to shoot Erik a
message on Facebook or Instagram
please turn all of his inboxes wherever
you may find them into a complete hell
hole showing overwhelming support for
keeping me on the show actually probably
a better way to do that would be go
wherever you get your podcast make sure
you like it leave a review and in the
review you can let us know who the the
permanent host should be I think Dwayne
Johnson would be a very good option but
he doesn't seem to answer my emails he's
I think he's been on vacation he got
married recently someone he gets back
we'll see oh good for him yeah we're all
very happy for him so I I haven't seen
video of that wedding but if her wedding
vows didn't include the line you are my
rock that marriage should be annulled I
think there there's got to be some kind
of legal precedent by which it be
completely invalid from the start one
would hope yeah all right Dwayne check
your email
talk to you soon congratulations okay so
before we get into the feats of strength
I have a segment that I'm calling the
air in the breathing
that is absolutely stolen from Seinfeld
so here's the thing so Greg is he'll
never admit this but he's one of the
hardest-working people I know
during his master's degree he was a
full-time student he was running a study
he was running two businesses he didn't
have a lot of time to Train and so you
know Greg if you follow him on Instagram
you know he's back in the gym lately and
he's essentially back to PR strength
levels you lobar squatted what like 600
for five the other day 605 four five six
oh five four five which I believe is
like that is a PR yes 600 was my old PR
right so so Greg in a matter of weeks is
like back and ready to go and when I say
he was like took some time off training
I mean he did not see the inside of a
gym for you may be worked out four times
over like a 12-month span maybe yeah I
think I got nine training sessions in
over two years right so that's not a
height in the spectrum of training
frequencies that's toward the lower end
correct you would agree I think there
are some people who train nine times in
a week so you hit that in a two-year
stretch which is that's low frequency
now for me like you know I've been
training around a hip thing which we all
know I've got a hip thing and then
obviously finishing the PhD and then
starting to work with mass and stronger
by science I've had some professional
stuff to check off my to-do list but you
know recently I was like okay I'm gonna
get back into the power lifts get my
squat deadlift and bench but that was
with really consistent training over the
last few years and I am so far away from
my PRS the soaps so like to give an
example the other day I put 73% of my
squat vest on the bar completely wrecked
my back catastrophic ly and I'm still
not alright like you
you saw me try to tie my shoes an hour
ago tying my shoes is off the table
right now yeah and the thing that's most
frustrating is not just that you're
strong already
but you wrecked your back like the first
week you got back into it to the extent
that one of our episodes I won't say
which you literally recorded it from bed
laying down yeah I couldn't sit up
we couldn't have you sit for an hour so
well one important thing to note is my
back is it will go from being really bad
to just fine pretty quickly so I don't
know exactly what is going on
structurally but I kind of think that
there I think it's like generally kind
of okay but if something bad happens
like a nerve gets impinged and as soon
as everything just relaxes back there
everything's back to normal
so that actually happened prior to the
last meet that I did I slipped on some
ice and landed awkwardly and hurt my
back and like three days out from the
meet I couldn't walk and then on meat
day it was still very painful but I was
somewhat functional still put together a
decent total and way off what I was
planning on but I mean still squatted
like 650 I mean didn't affect bench and
I pulled what I needed to to win my
classes like 560 give or take and then
but like so I was still way off my best
and in considerable pain and then two
days after that I pulled a trap bar
deadlift PR and everything was
completely fine so it's not like my back
issues are like chronic issues but it's
chronically not a big deal at all most
of the time and then occasionally a very
big deal for like three or four days and
then fine yeah it's just to me it's like
I didn't take anywhere near the lay off
you did I'm still infinite like I can't
even see
pyaare territory we're on that and the
fact that you like wrecked your back to
the extent like you were in bad shape
and you're already fine and my back when
it happened was not that big of a deal
there was never a day where I like
couldn't sit but it just isn't getting
any better
and so I'm just generally upset
frustrated mad and jealous okay so let's
move on to feats of strength yes so
several cool things happened this week
or not just this week but just kind of
recently so Kaler woolum recently dead
lifted 400 kilos conventional he so
Caylor has the deadlift world record in
the 110 kilo 242 pounds and it's like
should have looked it up before we
started recording but it's something
like 420 430 pounds like somewhere in
the low-to-mid 900 s and the the reason
I wanted to point this out is Caylor
gets a decent amount of hate for his
sumo deadlifts because if you wanted to
build someone who was perfectly built
for the deadlift they look a fair amount
like Caylor woolum and especially with
the sumo stance a lot of people get bent
out of shape about sumo and they're like
hat dude dudes not even that strong like
he just has long arms in the Chiti sumo
stance and bla bla bla but like if you
deadlift 400 kilos which is 880 pounds
conventional liked you're a strong
[ __ ] dude and this is something you
see with really good sumo deadlift errs
for the most part so I think I think
people get upset when they see a really
good efficient sumo deadlift because a
good sumo deadlift er makes the sumo
deadlift look so easy and people see
that and if they aren't built as well
for the sumo deadlift maybe they don't
have the hip mobility for it they see it
and they just think man if I was built
like that person
I could sumo deadlift in infinite amount
but I can't think of a really good sumo
deadlift er who isn't all also quite
strong conventional like Kaler wouldn't
be the world record holder in his weight
class if he pulled conventional but he'd
still pull 400 kilos which is a ton of
weight like most most really good sumo
deadlift ders can still pull at least 90
percent of their best suit sumo deadlift
conventional see ya big milestone for
him really good lift wanted to put that
on on the list so on the subject of
someone who is a very good very
efficient sumo deadlift er you you Rin
recently posted a video of himself dead
lifting eight hundred and fifteen pounds
he is an 83 kilo lifter I believe
competing in IPF affiliates and he has
the record in that weight class which is
three hundred and forty kilos which is
like seven hundred and forty nine pounds
so so he's you know training on a gym
bar with standard plates with the
thinner kilo plates and IPF competition
bar who knows what that eight fifteen
will translate to but for a lifter that
size 83 kilos deadlifting 815 also he
makes it look like a joke
and recently he also posted a video
pulling 775 for a triple so in and when
I talk about sumo perfection like Jesus
Christ as sumo deadlift looks incredible
so that's number two number three is I'm
thinking at USA PL Nationals this year
the 83 kilo squat record for the men is
going to get absolutely destroyed so the
current record is held by Russell o ream
I believe it's 690 pounds which
is a large number of kilograms like 315
give or take so anyway like that was at
world's last year and that was a very
very challenging looking lift so Russell
in the gym recently squatted 696 and
made it look super easy so over his
current world record made it look like
an empty bar also squatted 675 for a
triple also looked fairly comfortable so
he looks like he's primed to break his
own record the sleeper in that class
though need to give a shout out to my
boy Jamar royster trains at spider
strength gym same place I workout and so
in like the two years that I was out of
the sport in grad school I didn't
realize how [ __ ] strong Jamar got so
the last meet I did was Jamar's first
powerlifting meet and he had a
background in bodybuilding before that
like you you see the guy in like you
know he's strong but it was also
somewhat obvious that he wasn't
tremendously comfortable with
powerlifting yet like his technique was
good but he didn't quite look
comfortable hitting one rep Max's yet
which is pretty standard for people who
who make the switch to powerlifting but
I mean even then he was competing at 181
and I think he's he squatted either like
mid to high fives or maybe low sixes so
he obviously had the talent for it and
so I get out of school moved back to
Raleigh see Jamar and holy [ __ ] this
kid's gotten strong recently he Paul
squatted 6:39 for a triple and squatted
without a pause 672 for a double so I
think Russell still squats more than him
but I also think Jamar one is gonna give
him a run for his money
like don't sleep on him dude is dude as
a sleeper pick in that class but also
it's not gonna surprise me if there's
multiple people who squat 700 plus at 83
kilos at us APL Nationals this year
which will just be insane and then my my
last feat of strength for the day I
think this happened maybe like three or
four weeks ago but I just recently heard
about it so I'm gonna butcher the last
name but lusha talakad sir georgian
weightlifter super heavy currently the
best super heavyweight weightlifter in
the world and arguably the greatest of
all time
so in arguably based on the numbers he's
actually put up he has the highest
competition total in weightlifting
history the reason it's arguable is he
hasn't been at the top for that long so
he hasn't taken down as many world
championships and Olympic medals as as
some of the past greats but I recently
saw a video of him snatching 221 kilos
which is that's like 486 pounds I
believe and I mean like a max snatch
never looks hard like it doesn't look
like a max deadlift but grind a snatch
yeah yeah for sure but I mean just
looking at it like it looks like he has
more in the tank like oftentimes a max
snatch or clean and jerk will still
maybe look a little bit shaky but god he
made it look like a joke and on the same
post of him snatching 221 Gregor from
hook grip also said that there's a video
floating around that he hasn't posted
yet of washa clean and jerking 267 which
is I believe 590 pounds and like so one
of the things that makes me a little
upset about weightlifting currently is
just how much better Lasha is than every
other super heavy because he he doesn't
have to hit his max numbers to win
competent
anymore the the class just isn't as deep
as it used to be and like I'm pretty
sure he won world's last year by like 24
kilos or something crazy like that so I
don't know if we're ever going to have
occasion to see lasha have to push
himself in competition or whether he's
just gonna keep breaking his own total
record by one kilo at a time but I mean
if if he went to 21 to 67 in the same
competition that would just be stupid
and like I think everyone loves him just
because if you don't know who this guy
is just search Lasha and then tal and
the rest of his name should pop up so
you don't have to worry about spelling
it and just like look at the guy and how
much joy he lives with he just looks
like a huge generally jolly bear of a
man and probably the strongest
weightlifter who's ever lived so I think
that does it for my feats of strength
for the week yep I'm gonna swoop in with
one and we've had bodybuilders on feats
of strength before we had Dexter Jackson
we've also used the segment to to
memorialize strength athletes that have
passed and unfortunately about an hour
before we started recording we just
heard that unfortunately Franco Columbu
has passed away so I believe he was 78
Franco Columbu absolute legend he's
another one of those guys that whenever
you saw him pictures videos he just
looked like he was loving it you know
what I mean seemed like a very joyful
really happy dude who just loved
everything about the world of iron you
know so everybody knows him obviously as
a bodybuilding legend
I believe he won both the mr. universe
and mr. Olympia titles at least in his
class you know back then they would have
liked the weight cut off set height
cut-offs depending on which organization
this is I mean the infancy of
bodybuilding really
as in terms of like the modern
competitions that you see so things have
changed a lot in bodybuilding but
whenever there was a short class or a
kind of a lower weight cutoff it was
always Franco and whenever they had the
taller weight class or the heavier it
was Arnold you know so if you don't know
their background they were great friends
they really did it's hard to overstate
how much attention and value they
brought to the bodybuilding world you
know that they were kind of the the face
of it as I was mentioning though Franco
not not just a bodybuilder really did
just about everything you'd hope to do
in the strength world you know he did
1977 - the World's Strongest Man
competition it was known to be a very
good lifter in the powerlifting realm of
things so this is based on Wikipedia
numbers I'm not like a strength
historian by any means but best
benchpress was listed as 525 best quwata
655 best deadlift as 750 so I I didn't
know about the bench and squat but that
the deadlift is pretty well documented
yeah there's apparently rumors that in
training he had died lifted over 780
don't know if that's verified or not
I mean dewd stage weight was 185 right
yeah so those lifts were probably done
it somewhere in the vicinity of 200
pounds probably which I mean there was
because you've never seen him not
looking damn lean right yeah so I mean a
deadlift in the mid to high 70s at 200 I
mean that still holds up really well
today yeah and apparently he was also an
amateur boxing champ back in Italy so
like he was just kind of like one of
those guys that like if it involved
being strong or punching a dude or
anything within the realm it's like yeah
I'll give it a shot but but yeah he
certainly is one of the legends one of
the greats
rest in peace Franco thanks for
everything you did for the strength
world in general and I think that does
it for the segment all right so now
we're gonna move on to a segment called
Coach's Corner and normally Gregg uses
this as a platform to talk about some
stupid stuff about women how do you draw
whatever but this week I'm gonna talk
about nutrition and metabolism which is
what people really like so because of
some of the work I've done in the past
some of the articles I've written I get
a lot of messages on the internet about
metabolic adaptation so basically the
whole the whole mess of hormonal changes
and changes in energy expenditure that
happen when you start reducing your
caloric intake and losing weight and so
on one hand I definitely empathize with
it because I've been there
and it's weird when you start losing a
lot of weight for the first time you can
kind of feel that your hormones are
changing and you feel different and it's
a little bit troubling at first cuz you
don't feel great and you also notice
that your caloric intake is starting to
get really low and you start to worry a
little bit like how low is this gonna
have to get but sometimes when I get
these messages even though I know where
they're coming from and I empathize with
them I kind of feel like I'm in the hull
of a ship and the year 1690 and I'm the
doctor and they're asking me like is it
scurvy like we don't know we don't
really know what it is or what to do
about it but it's definitely gonna be
terrible and you're probably gonna die
like it's treated like this binary thing
like have I caught the metabolic
adaptation and if so am I screwed and
people want to know like am I screwed is
it normal for my calories to be this low
and how low are they gonna have to get
for me to actually get as lean as I want
to be and the answer is like I don't
really know because there's a lot of
variability to consider but I think the
best way to illustrate the point is with
some numbers so using just like basic
predictive equations I kind of jotted
down some numbers that were similar to a
person my size and you know in the
offseason to maintain my my body weight
just purely based on predictive
equations with a pretty conservative
activity factor
it might be like 26 30 you know 2630
calories a day but what a lot of people
fail to notice or recognize is metabolic
adaptation happens in both directions
and I wrote about this many years ago
with Eric Helms before we had a falling
out and started to dislike each other a
lot but back then he was doing good
stuff now he's a joke but we wrote about
this we're like based on the literature
it's not atypical when you're like kind
of bulking you can inflate your your
normal energy expenditure throughout the
day by about 10% just as a function of
overeating like so when you're in a
surplus your metabolic rate your total
energy expenditure tends to ramp up a
little bit sometimes up to 10% and so
what that means is instead of eating
26:30 now you're talking more close to
20 900 calories a day and so then you
know you go through all this weight loss
for me on a prep I'll lose about 40
pounds give or take and at that point a
predictive equation would put me at like
2300 calories but metabolic adaptation
works the other direction as well so if
I'm like 15% below that now I've gone to
like 1945 and that's for maintenance
correct for maintenance yeah
and so what we're talking about there is
the swing that I'm noticing on my end is
I used to eat like 2900 and now I'm
under 2,000 to maintain then I apply a
deficit which will probably be three
hundred six hundred calories a day all
of a sudden as an adult man I'm eating
like fourteen hundred and fifty calories
a day and I used to eat like close to
three thousand a day and so sometimes
you look at those numbers and you think
something is going horribly wrong here
but in reality you all we have to do is
factor in a little bit of variability a
little bit of shifting in either
direction whether you're bulking or
cutting and these numbers get a lot less
scary you know these are the reason I
write about metabolic adaptation a lot
is because it's important to plan for
you know a lot of people think oh well
I'm maintaining at 3,000 calories I'll
just cut 500 calorie
and cruise on into competition yeah yeah
or maybe I'll have to drop another 200 a
lot of people noticed that there's
almost a dead zone when it comes to the
calories they can maintain on mm-hmm
where you know if you try to go into a
really conservative deficit and maybe
cut your calories by a hundred a day
just nothing happens yeah or same thing
if you go into like a really small
surplus so there is there's like a I
think people I think people use the word
only a lot when they implying that
something is is negligible when it
actually isn't so when the whole thing
about starvation mode was huge back in
the day and people were like oh if we
look at the Minnesota starvation
experiment we see that excessive
metabolic adaptation was only another 15
percent but the thing is when that's 15
percent from you know a baseline that
was already used to be higher because
you used to be bigger you're talking
about a lot of calories there right and
so like to put those numbers into
context if I purely looked at what
should my intake have been to maintain
at my starting weight versus my ending
weight with none of those adaptations
mixed in that's a difference based on
the estimation equations of like 342
calories but when you build in the 10%
upward from bulking and the 15% downward
from the more classical metabolic
adaptation that gap of 342 becomes a
total gap of 948 that's a lot that's a
big number and so that's kind of why I
like to write about metabolic adaptation
it's not something to be afraid of it's
certainly not insurmountable there are
ways around it and it's better to plan
for it than to be blindsided by it but
this is why people get into these
situations where they're like I
absolutely cannot explain this
discrepancy in my weight loss and it's
like well we've failed to budget in
these pretty sizable fluctuations in
both directions mm-hmm and another thing
to keep in mind that makes it even more
challenging is there's been researchers
have estimated that two individuals the
same body size their non-exercise
activity thermogenesis just based on the
lifestyle they live can vary by up to
2,000 calories per day
now that's extreme that's like the a
maximal kind of range but it makes it
when you consider all these variations
and overfeeding and underfeeding and
kind of natural variation in resting
metabolic rate and typical variation and
non-exercise activity and and the fact
that non exercise activity tends to go
up in a surplus and down in a deficit
right but when you consider all those
sources of variability when you look at
someone else on Instagram and you say
why are they losing weight at 1600
calories and I'm not it really
highlights how silly of a practice that
is like the idea that you can just kind
of eyeball it and be like well if they
diet on that then I should be able to
lose weight on that yeah so there's a
lot of variability and in episode 14 in
the interview portion we've got Brandon
Roberts on and he just did a competition
like last week and I asked him I'm
always curious like how bad did it get
here you know I never want to ask like
hey how's training out I'm always like
how how should he has this gotten and at
his lowest days on his diet he said he
was around 1,300 calories cool buddy
bran is not a small guy yeah
and so like every now and then I'll get
a message from somebody who's like 40
pounds lighter or thirty pounds lighter
than Brandon they're like is it possible
I'll have to go under 1,500 calories and
I'm like oh yeah yeah you know like it's
not great but that's that's the week
ends unless you're just doing a
tremendous amount of cardio right which
I would argue is a much less pleasant
experience you'd rather just cut the
calories I wonder how many people do a
bunch of cardio just so they can like
flex about how many calories they're
eating on Instagram hopefully none but
probably a lot yeah yeah that's that's
kind of what what I think yeah I mean
all of it my bias is that I'm extra
the anti cardio as a fat loss mechanism
I'm about as extreme as you get on that
spectrum but in any case the reason I
bring this up if you're someone who is
worried about metabolic adaptation and
you're wondering do I have it the more
the more valid question based on the
research is not do you have it but -
what magnitude are you experiencing it
this is a thing that happens on a
spectrum some people are more responsive
to it than others and more importantly
these things are all quantifiable there
are no mysteries here there are reasons
for these changes that can be
troubleshot you know you can get with
somebody who has an understanding of
this literature and start to figure out
how you can start to make this a more
tolerable experience how to mitigate
some of these things but yeah the
important thing is it's nothing to be
worried about or scared about it is
something to plan for it can certainly
be overcome okay so it's not scurvy it's
not like all your teeth are gonna fall
out and then we're just gonna push it
overboard and everything's cool but yeah
that's the probably the most common
question I get is like people really
panicked about it and it's tough because
when you ride in and and talk about it a
lot people are like well you're the one
who told me to worry about it and as I
know I told you to consider it but not
to worry about it yeah yeah now we've
got a special part to to this week's
coaches corner segment and I'm gonna let
Greg take it away yeah so oftentimes in
coaches corner will tell you what is a
good idea to do or a good idea to at
least try but I actually want to make
you aware of something that you very
much should not do and probably should
not try I was recently reminded of this
just earlier today and every time I'm
reminded of it I think it doesn't fully
stick because of how outrageous it is
and so the thing I'm going to recommend
you not do is collect your urine and
inject it into your
so you may ask and say hey why why would
that even be a thing that would come to
mind in the first place and so famous or
potentially infamous biohacker
Dave Asprey of a bulletproof executive
it into yourself as a way to treat
allergies and what reminded me of it is
someone messaged me on Instagram and
sent me the article and said hey Greg
this doesn't seem right do you have any
insight
I said yeah don't do it man like so the
you know it's a controversial approach
in the medical field I think yes so my
favorite line of this article is urine
injection therapy is controversial in
the medicine in the medicine in the
medical world which like no it's not I
kind of the controversial implies that
there are two sides of the discussion to
have a controversy I'm pretty sure it's
a very uncontroversial no in the medical
world and then the next sentence many
people say it's nonsense
sidebar yes of course they [ __ ] do
sentence continues and there are a few
parentheses if any Studies on it and
there are no links attached to that
sentence like the parenthetical if any
is doing very heavy lifting in that
sense so anyway but it does highlight
the fact that the current medical
literature is an incomplete literature
we haven't turned over all the rocks
technically true but I don't know how
relevant that is in this case but yeah
so just to kind of make a somewhat
larger point one of the things that
people ask me to do the most
frequently either on this podcast or on
the website is to do like quote-unquote
debunking work in generally that's not
what I'm about i I think that I don't
know I think people oftentimes are just
like too aggressive with debunking don't
exercise the principle of charity
sufficiently oftentimes it comes across
as somewhat bad faith and I I think that
I think it also just isn't all that
useful because for the most part if
you're if you're coming out really hard
against an idea generally you're
communicating that to to people who
generally agree with you already and so
it's more just like getting kudos and
back Pat's from your tribe versus
getting the information to the people
who could who could potentially benefit
from it and just generally the way that
most like quote unquote debunking is
done things aren't phrased in a way that
will help build a bridge to help like
convince people who may have believed
previously the thing you're trying to
debunk and say yeah don't do much
debunking don't do many call-outs
because I I mean I think most people in
the fitness industry generally mean well
and aren't just complete charlatans but
anytime I attempt to give Dave Asprey
the benefit of the doubt and I remember
he wrote an article about injecting
yourself with urine and then another one
about how you should drop your pants and
get 15 to 20 minutes of direct sunlight
per day on your balls to boost
testosterone I have a tremendously
difficult time doing that so anyway one
of the rear call-outs you're gonna
you're gonna hear on this podcast or
from stronger by science stuff in
general don't Sun your balls don't
inject yourself with urine
Dave Asprey generally am not of the
opinion that he's a good faith actor
yeah and I mean so Greg
Imoh is the one who's like really
cautious about like what goes into the
podcast and what doesn't and like when
you mention this article I was like now
that sounds slanderous and then I
thought about and I was like all you're
doing is saying a thing that he
published yeah I mean I'm not trying to
put words in his mouth like I know can
read the article for for yourself no I
was like it does a collect your urine in
a sterile container and inject it into
yourself and that will help treat
allergies like come on you know I
exercise a great deal of caution in that
realm and when you you're a nut you are
much more restrained than I am yeah and
you said you were gonna attribute those
ideas to him and I said that's
completely out of bounds aim on you and
then I realized all you're doing is
bringing attention to an article that he
purposely put his name on yeah and and
the thing is before like before I was
going to talk about this on the podcast
I went to make sure that like oh maybe
he put a correction in the article maybe
he delisted it or something like that
but no like [ __ ] things still up
there there's nothing to indicate that
his views on this have changed and I
mean so my opinion is that he is
probably a bad faith actor I will leave
open the possibility that he's not and
maybe he is just that gullible that he
legitimately thinks that you know [ __ ]
allergists [ __ ] modern medicine there
are like sterile well tested allergy
shots which I will note I have a lot of
experience with like I spent eight years
of my childhood getting allergy shots
like three times a week it made a huge
difference to my life like it works and
it's medicine because it's well studied
and essentially what he's proposing with
urine injections is the same concept as
allergy shots like expose yourself to
something you may be a little allergic
to you'll produce antibodies maybe some
of those antibodies will collect in your
urine and then you can inject that into
yourself which is kind of the same thing
you're getting with allergy shots like
gradual exposure to an allergen to like
hopefully decrease your body's response
to it but like you can get the same
thing without injecting yourself with
piss and usually like if you don't know
what you're doing it's usually a good
idea you shouldn't be injecting yourself
with anything yeah you know leave that
to the pros yeah I mean like yeah
injecting yourself with something is
really like the nuclear option when it
comes to experimenting on yourself
because unless you unless you eat
something that's incredibly toxic your
liver protects you from stupidity before
stuff actually gets into your blood and
general circulation right like you have
you have the barrier of your intestines
like stuff has to be absorbed it's gonna
go through your liver hopefully like if
something's really bad a decent amount
of it will get metabolized on the first
pass but like if you're putting
something straight into your blood
you better know for damn sure what
you're doing because you're taking out
like two or three lines of your body's
built-in safety precautions against
[ __ ] yourself up like yeah just the
idea of injecting yeah disregard the
fact it's urine like unless you're a
doctor or you have clear instructions
about exactly how much to inject in what
way of something like how to do it yeah
like maybe you get like the maybe you do
like daily intramuscular testosterone
injections for like TRT or maybe you
like you use an insulin or maybe have an
EpiPen like those are things that it's
it's a fixed dose of something that you
have a prescription for that you have
been trained to do it's not just [ __ ]
willy-nilly piss in a cup draw it up in
a syringe and hope for the best
like that's that's so outrageous to me
yeah and the thing and the thing is it's
it's probably in general not that day
because as Rip Torn said in dodgeball do
I have to drink my own urine
no but it's sterile and I like the taste
the only part of that that I wanted to
draw attention to is it's sterile
so generally urine is sterile so like
that kind of helps I guess but then if
you get a [ __ ] UTI it's not sterile
anymore and you're just injecting [ __ ]
into yourself it's dumb it's and it's
it's so dumb and the more I think about
its product yeah it went out for a
reason man Eric have you come across the
people online who who think that urine
is like a wonder drug no I don't I if I
could do my job without having to
actually go on the internet I would so
so those people exist and I'm not trying
to attribute this to a spree I don't
think that he's one of these folks but
there are there are people who believe
that one of the healthiest things you
can do for yourself is collect and Rican
soom your own urine and so one I'm just
putting that out there because a if
there is if there's a pseudo scientific
belief that is ripe for for people to
like make jokes about online I think
that's a good one like Flat Earth yeah
it's funny but like that's [ __ ]
played out people have been making Flat
Earth jokes non-stop for the last two or
three years they were funny at first now
they're just old auntie facts stuff also
crazy but also I have a hard time
finding it funny because you know there
could be kids dying of easily
preventable diseases but drinking your
own piss that's funny and it hasn't been
mocked as much as it could slash should
be so I'm proposing that the next time
you're on Facebook or Instagram and you
want to make a flat earth joke make a
piss drinking joke instead yeah I also
like that
within this you brought up the the idea
of just like jumping off the top rope
and saying like a very obvious thing to
dunk on a stupid idea mm-hmm like like
the the debunking kind of culture of
like the the the feeling I get i I don't
get this
nearly as much as you do but if someone
were to like hit up my inbox and be like
hey people are being wrong on the
internet go dunk on them
I'd be like like dude I just don't - who
is this productive these people feel
very strongly about this thing just
about everybody that's not in that camp
knows that it's a really dumb idea so I
just I don't see the utility of me
jumping in there and saying hey did you
know everyone in the world disagrees
with you and then they say yeah it's
because the world is wrong like that's
gonna happen
11 times out of 10 so if you go into
that hostile territory and tell them
they're doing dumb stuff they don't care
they've heard it before yeah they think
you're an idiot and if you do it to your
people and say hey look at these people
I'm dunking on then you're just gonna
get the like 30,000 likes you know slap
on the back you got them this time Greg
like I just don't see a lot of utility
in that no I I agree and I I think I
think what you said contains a lot of
truth that if you're going for a dunk
and not just trying to calmly explain
stuff it's probably just going to
reinforce what they already think
because a lot of those beliefs are kind
of conspiratorial like you know modern
nutrition or modern medical science has
been like corrupted by big money
interests and big pharma and blah blah
blah and like it's all wrong and
fraudulent and then if you come in and
say like hey guess what modern medical
and nutrition science disagrees with you
like that is reminding them of a core
tenant of their beliefs that like yes
these people disagree with us and
they're all wrong and corrupt like it's
it's not meeting people but it's not
meeting people where they are and
communicating with them in a way that
will be
affective to change hearts and minds so
the one thing that I will do sometimes
is like if someone's wrong I often don't
care because a lot of times I mean if
it's like if it's something lifting
related in someone just says something I
generally disagree with I'm not gonna
get worked up about it because generally
it just doesn't matter so for example
there's there's a ton of people who will
claim very confidently that you know you
should do two sets of polls for every
set of pressing you do and that's like
the key to saving your shoulders or
something I don't necessarily agree with
that and I also generally disagree with
how confidently they state it because
they state it as if it's a proven fact
right when to the best of my knowledge
there's absolutely no research on it or
if there is it's maybe weak and
circumstantial but like what's the worst
case scenario here someone does a bunch
of rows and now has big lats like fine
you know like like that's not something
I'm gonna go out of my way to to
ferociously combat because like I think
it's probably wrong but it's not harmful
if someone does it it's the difference
between somebody being like hey I enjoy
ketogenic diet like fine I'm sure you're
gonna do fine with it
versus like hey I have an infant and I
only feed them ground-up beef well I
mean there's a way to find out if that's
the best diet for infants there is yeah
so a few months ago Lane Norton got into
it on Twitter with what's her name
Michaela or mihaela or something like
that I think it's Michaela okay Jorden
Peterson's daughter who like is a very
vocal proponent for the carnivore diet
which is exactly what it sounds like if
you know what it means to be carnivorous
you know what this diet is which like
for adults yeah
I mean it's probably not the best idea
like scurvy exists but it also doesn't
strike me as a diet that people are
going to have perfect adherence to so
whatever I think it's kind of dumb but
if an adult wants to try it
I don't care like I'm not gonna lose
sleep over it it's a bad idea but you're
allowed to make bad decisions
correct adult yeah so if memory serves
she said something about like having her
kids do it and I'm no pediatrician but
my my general understanding is that kids
benefit from having more in their diet
than just steak for like optimal growth
and development and so like Lane said
something and called her out and they
got into a big argument if the the the
crescendo of the argument at least for
me personally was she was like well
there's one way to settle this my kid
can beat yours in a footrace like other
than of the many ways that one could
potentially resolve that issue like oh
let's check out PubMed okay like you're
you're not that into the medical science
like I don't know like like do a case
study with like a single individual
whatever yeah or you or you could be
like hey look my child with these
different developmental markers is
everything's fine we're doing it right
yeah like there there are many different
ways that one could adjudicate that
argument with with varying degrees of
rigor but jumping straight to well my
kids [ __ ] faster than yours therefore
you're full of [ __ ] Lane get off Twitter
like that was that was tremendous like
that that much like the injecting piss
article is one of the things that every
time I remember it happened I just laugh
like it's it's a it's like a Kafka Eska
moment we're just the the pure absurdity
of it the only thing you can do is is
laugh at it
that's all you can do alright so moving
on to our next segment we have one
called question of the day and the
question is what are some big things
that you've changed your mind about over
the years I definitely have some that
come to mind immediately for me but I'm
gonna kick this over to you to start
with Eric what are some things that you
used to believe very strongly that
you've I don't know maybe just generally
change your opinion on or possibly done
a complete 180 about yeah that it's a
good question I also think it's like
it's kind of like a gut check for people
that say like oh I'm evidence-based in
my approach it's like if someone is but
they've never changed their mind on
anything it kind of makes you wonder if
they actually do continue to seek new
evidence and implement it you know I
mean maybe they are that one person that
all of their first assumptions were
entirely correct but probably not mm-hmm
so I've got a few in mind some are
training some nutrition on the training
side I grew up my first exposure to
bodybuilding was from one of my
wrestling coaches back in the day really
great dude and we trained together we
really got after it but a lot of our
workouts were from like the muscle
magazines you know you it'd be like the
page you rip out and feel like hey this
is what we're doing for the next four
weeks or whatever and a lot of those are
really emphasized they like bodybuilders
split so like we're gonna go in today
and we would often add stuff on top of
it because we just we just really like
training man and so we'd be like so
we're gonna start with this but really
what's gonna happen is we're gonna go do
chest for about 90 minutes you know and
like if you're doing chest for 90
minutes it's a lot of chest yeah for one
day yeah and so a lot of my first
exposure to to training in the
bodybuilding context was extremely high
volume per session and for a long time I
thought that was the way to go and it's
easy to lead yourself down that path
because you walk out of the gym and
you're
like you know you do a 90 minute armed
day you're like I'm not gonna be able to
like zip up my jacket tomorrow yeah you
don't have any proof that it was an
effective session but you have ample
proof that you did some [ __ ] to your
arms yeah you're like something happened
yeah you walk out of the gym you are
completely wrecked and you're like that
seems like it should have been effective
because I can hardly move but but you
know the more that I train in different
methods and and the more that I
obviously look at the literature on
training I think that there's absolutely
some really I think there's a pretty
steep cliff there when it comes to
diminishing returns within a session and
you've brought this up before I forget
when we were chatting about it it may or
may not have been in front of a
microphone but it was for a audio of
roundtable for mass yeah for mass but it
is one of those things that is a really
important consideration for the the
literature looking at how much volume is
quote unquote optimal within a given
week is whether or not that's happening
in one session or spread spread
throughout several you know because 30
sets for a muscle group looks very
different if you did that on Wednesday
versus if you did 10 sets Monday
Wednesday and Friday those are two very
different stimuli for training so in any
case my width in session volume over the
years has really fallen it's really
dropped quite a bit and my training
frequency has picked up a little bit
sometimes in more extreme ways like
currently I'm doing like full-body
workouts at least you know three to five
times a week but even you know
transitioning from a pure body building
once a week split down to like a
push-pull legs or an upper lower kind of
split like did I read cebause as split
out as I get these days as may be doing
push-pull legs but going really a
training six days a week so that I'm
getting everything twice a week
another thing is meal frequency and
Perry workout nutrition I used to be of
the mind that you gotta eat as
frequently as possible and you know
right before the gym right after the gym
and aside from just being a really
annoying way to live as a person like I
think I told you sweet potatoes were
ruined for me I couldn't I couldn't go
near a sweet potato for like three years
mm-hmm
because my first bodybuilding diet sweet
potatoes were like one of my main carb
sources obviously because it was you
know traditional bodybuilding diet and I
had to eat frequently and I had a
cadaver anatomy course this is when I
was in undergrad oh yeah and you told me
about this so I had to always like it
was a long lab and so I would have to
sit in the hallway of the cadaver lab
and eat my sweet potatoes in like the
whole building just reeks of
formaldehyde so like in my mind I could
not separate the taste of a sweet potato
from the smell of formaldehyde those two
were intrinsically linked for years
thankfully I've gotten over that and I
can dive into some sweet potato fries
which is a big thing for me but but yeah
the the meal frequency it's a really
inconvenient way to live and it
completely just it it's really not
representative we like to believe we
have this perfect control over the time
course of like when amino acids enter
our bloodstream and when they peak and
when they need to get spiked again I
think we delude ourselves into thinking
we have a lot more power than we do in
terms of meal timing generally speaking
I think if you're lifting hard at least
three meals a day it might be nice to
spread them kinda evenly but even like
the eight hour feeding windows in time
restricted feeding studies seem to be
fine so I've really come around on meal
frequency and I used to be like Oh at
least five or six now I'm like at least
three and can you get away with time
restricted feeding or intermittent
fasting the evidence it's not a large
body of evidence but it would suggest
yes one of the things that's striking to
me is so like I felt the same thing as
well that like small frequent meals were
kind of a key
and one of the things that's striking to
me is going back and looking at fitness
information from the 90s and early 2000s
the thing that strikes me is how strong
that take was so if you read basically
any body builders or any Fitness persons
takes on you know what it takes to lose
fat and build muscle that was like the
first tip anyone would give so it wasn't
given yeah yeah yeah it wasn't like yeah
first thing you need to do is you know
make sure you're eating enough protein
and your calories are in line it's like
first things first buy stock and
Tupperware buy [ __ ] forty pieces of
Tupperware if you're not eating eight
meals a day why are you even trying and
then once you have that you know big
thing locked down yeah then maybe look
at protein you know like that no that's
how it was presented which in hindsight
is wild but I think that's why you me
and everyone thought that meal frequency
was so big because it was it was
unquestioned as like the most important
thing and I think since everyone who had
credibility was saying it I think
everyone just kind of went along with it
yeah I mean it was there was no pushback
on that whatsoever until intermittent
fasting kind of came around it became a
thing so I think that's been a really
like I don't think intermittent fasting
is like the be-all end-all of nutrition
but I do think it was helpful to have
that conversation kind of shift way
toward the other end of the spectrum so
we could kind of recalibrate how we view
meal frequency and that's another
example of like sometimes weighing like
whether somebody's necessarily correct
versus doing something harmful that's
another thing like if someone tells me
about their meal frequency there's so
much wiggle room in terms of how you can
make a good die at work like if you were
telling me that you have eight meals a
day or two I don't view any of those as
being absolutely catastrophic whereas
like back in the day if you told me I
only have two meals a day and they're
kind of
together I'd be like dude are you are
out of your mind if that's what you're
doing now I'm like okay it might not
necessarily be perfect but you're fine
mm-hmm
and that kind of leads me to another
thing on the view anew on the nutrition
side of things I used to really get
caught up in like overly mechanistic
views of nutrition and while they are
very appealing especially to people who
are drawn to very nuanced approaches and
their training and nutrition like
sometimes people really enjoy getting
way down into the details and I
understand why but when it comes to
nutrition I've definitely shifted more
toward comprehensive views versus overly
mechanistic views of how we eat and the
reason is the more that you follow each
trajectory of like hey here's this thing
that we should go in and tweak like a
very specific nutrient or even down to
like metabolites of particular amino
acids the more we follow those they more
often than not lead to dead ends you
know so like a great example is this is
just a for instance but we we started to
figure out hey turns out the branched
chain of meat and amino acids seem to
have something to do with protein
synthesis seem to be pretty good with
muscle protein synthesis and so then
people go nuts about branched chain
amino acids and then they say actually
we could just take leucine and forget
the rest of them and we just take
leucine and then we're like well
actually there's like three different
metabolites of leucine that might all be
kind of cool and we go down that road
and it's just like the more we try to go
down these really specific very
mechanistic viewpoints of like how can
we cheat the system and turn muscles on
in terms of protein synthesis
I still think you take a step back and
it's like well you have to eat enough
protein and probably have at least a
couple meals a day and that's about as
as good as we can do so I've gotten away
from you know I'll still follow them as
a it's interesting to look at some of
these potential things where people say
hey here's the thing we could
and certainly we should always be open
to that and start following the research
where it leads but I follow it more with
interest and less with optimism if that
makes sense yeah like I'm a lot more
skeptical when someone says hey here's
this thing we can exploit and I'll be
like ah interesting let's see if it
works usually we end up falling back on
some main core nutritional principles I
got you yeah and then finally my
eagerness to use dietary supplements has
changed a lot back in the day when I was
first getting into fitness I was so
stoked about just about anything that
seems like it might be useful you know
like back in the day I made a
pre-workout when I was in college like
just bought all the ingredients and
mixed them together because it was fun
and it was still a good there are more
destructive ways to spend your time as a
young man so it was a good learning
experience I think but man I look back
at the stuff I put in it and I'm like
God all of that was useless like almost
everything do you remember what it was
oh yeah so I remember I would I put in
obviously caffeine and creatine I'd put
in beta alanine I'd put in l-arginine
which tastes horrible I've never had
arginine it's terrible and it also fun
fact doesn't work and I put in branched
chain amino acids which were unflavored
which tasted like rubbish and didn't mix
at all so there'd just be chalk at the
top of my drink wait I I think he may
have had bad stuff that's extremely
plaza yeah I think I think the
solubility of branched chain amino acids
is supposed to be quite high well
whatever I got was not doing well maybe
it's because I was jamming so many paths
maybe that's just the last thing I put
in it was like nope
yeah fair enough like this mixture is
tapped out yeah fair enough but in any
case yeah so I've become a lot more
skeptical about dietary supplements I
keep my my supplement rotation extremely
slim compared to when I was young and
optimistic and you know you'd see the
advertisement and you're like well it
does say science is in there and then
you just jump on it you know yeah
did you ever use glutamine I did I think
you know what I think that was also in
the mix today yeah so I had this kick
for a while where I mean based on what I
was reading in muscle magazines and on
the internet I thought that the key to
getting a good training response was to
to spike your growth hormone and so
there was that one study on glutamine
from way back in the day where it
apparently increased post-exercise
growth hormone production by like twelve
twelve hundred percent or something like
that which to the best of my knowledge
that study was never replicated but I
mean you really only need one study for
supplement marketing copy correct and so
I used glutamine there was some research
looking at the post-workout growth
hormone spike from using pre-workout
melatonin I remember that yeah so I
would take low-dose melatonin which
actually I think worked out pretty well
for me so I'm I'm defined low-dose like
500 micrograms okay so I'm just now
thinking back about this when I was
doing that I was sleeping pretty well
and I've read some stuff about melatonin
suggesting that it's better to take it
kind of in the afternoon when melatonin
levels would start gradually rising in
the first place and then when evening
and night hits kind of once you have
that process rolling your own natural
melatonin production can take over I
don't know how much research there is on
that but I know I've seen that
proposed as a way to use melatonin and
thinking back about that time period I
was actually sleeping quite well so so
maybe that was good but not for the
growth hormone and then also training
fasted so I was I that was during a
period where just just to give context
about how stupid I was I thought that
like a high meal frequency was necessary
but I also thought I needed to Train
fasted to spike my post-workout growth
hormone and so that meant skipping my
pre-workout meal which meant that I was
still eating like three hours before I
went to the gym so I was nowhere
particularly close to a fasted state but
you traded a three-hour fast I mean but
back then it was like oh you're supposed
to eat every like two or three hours so
if if I hadn't eaten in three hours and
I wasn't gonna eat until after the gym
so I was gonna go five hours between
meals I was like holy [ __ ] could could a
human be more faster than this
so yeah I to do that I'm sure you
remember back in the day people would
would talk about waking themselves up to
like chug a protein shake oh hell yeah
yeah and I'm like dude sleep is worth so
much more than that yeah so I actually
had a system worked out to do that so I
am a really heavy sleeper and the only
the only thing that's going to wake me
up in the middle of the night is if I if
I have to pee like it's literally an
emergency anything else I'm gonna sleep
through I've slept through a hurricane
I've slept through a gunshot in my room
no one was trying to shoot at me that's
a long story anyway like I sleep through
everything so what I would do to make
sure I could get my middle-of-the-night
protein is I would chug like over half a
gallon of water right before I went to
bed so I would wake up at like 4:00 a.m.
needing to pee and I would have a
pre-mixed protein
shake like sitting right next to the
toilet so when I went to pee I could
just grab the protein shake and chug it
and and make sure that I was never
catabolic you're lucky you didn't just
start pissing the bed every day I mean I
don't sleep that hard so okay now into
some of the stuff I had written down I
mean like dude it's one of the things
that is made clear to me is how much
I've changed my mind about because one
of the things that at least once or
twice a week this happens and it always
makes me cringe a little bit is I'll see
something that I previously wrote like a
long time ago get linked somewhere on
the internet and someone says well Greg
Knuckles thinks X Y Z and it's like a
present tense verb like Greg knuckles
thinks or Greg knuckles says not you
know thought in 2011 or said in 2012 if
I go and look back at it and think ooh
buddy this ain't good and I I don't
remember like all of the instances where
that's occurred and largely it's on
sites other than my own a couple years
ago I went through stronger by science
and made private all of the old articles
that I really no longer agree with
anymore it's like there's still there's
probably some stuff on the site still
that I'm like yeah not sure I'm like
super super sure about that but like my
really bad takes I took off
but anyway so I've changed my mind about
a lot of stuff one of the big ones is I
used to be super super pro keto and and
I think that this is I think this is one
of the reasons why I am pretty tolerant
of people who are wrong but not
dangerous is I mean like I I think the
right thing about keto is that it's a
perfectly viable dietary strategy for
most people I used to think that it was
you know magic
it was keto intermittent fasting so it
was like you know no insulin all of the
growth hormone hell yeah gonna turn me
into a fat-burning muscle-building
machine in hindsight like no but I mean
I thought that it worked fine when I
went back to a more normal diet where I
was eating more than two meals a day and
consuming carbs it was better but like
the keto was fine and like what
eventually got me to change my mind was
you know exposing myself to more
research and I think of anything
I stayed stuck in in that kind of
pattern longer than I would have
otherwise been because a lot of the
people I now agree with like I came
across there takes on social media and I
was like god damn these people are
[ __ ] because whenever they would
talk about keto it was mostly in a very
like condescending and derisively and I
think that that actually kept me doing
keto than I would have otherwise like
fer for longer yeah I feel like we've
all been there though with keto yeah you
know it's the hardest thing in the world
because I'll try to give like a pretty
even-keeled nuanced take on keto and be
like listen it's probably fine generally
but like it's not better and like that
bad enough is that alone is often enough
to set some people off which is pretty
wild
yeah so another thing I've changed my
mind about several different times is
training frequency so much like you I
used to do a lower frequency I got into
fitness more on the powerlifting side of
things than the bodybuilding side of
things but this was during a period of
time when like Westside was still the
biggest name in the game and Louie
advocates like little workouts for like
accessory work but the main template is
you know to lower body days a week to
upper body days a week and this was also
around the time that Jim Windler was
starting to get more popular and I don't
know really what he says these days but
back then one of the things that he was
really pushing is like you know lifters
don't emphasize recovery enough like
maybe some of these guys are training
too much too frequently not giving
themselves adequate time to recover and
adapt and so what I ended up doing was
like a modified West Side template where
I was doing like one week would be to
lower body and one upper body day and
then the next week would be to upper
body one lower body day so is basically
taking the standard template and
stretching it out into nine or ten days
and I thought that that was like the
perfect balance of you know Louise
perfect system combined with the insight
that people need to take more time to
recover and so yeah like my typical
frequency for like my first few years of
training was about one and a half times
a week on average and then I got really
into Shaco stuff which was somewhat
higher frequency I got into the like MSM
si C programs pretty quickly which if
memory serves was like squatting three
or four days a week pulling two or three
and benching like four or five days a
week give or take had a fair amount of
success with that then experimented with
Bulgarian style training which was you
know ramping my frequency up from you
know squatting three or four days a week
to two or three times a day getting in
prob probably averaging about 1517
probably averaging between 16 and 18
squat and bench workouts a week so like
the super high end of things and I was
like kind of an advocate for high
frequency training for basically
everyone for a while and now that's been
significantly moderated like I do think
a frequency of at least twice a week is
generally gonna be better for most
people for most lifts most of the time
in a frequency of just once a week but
I'm I'm much less in the you know three
to five plus days per week camp then
then I once was another just general
thing is I'm much more accepting of
inter-individual differences than I used
to be and I think the thing that helped
the most with that was actually coaching
people and this is something that I've
noticed folks who actually coach or our
personal trainers or the like you know
work to try to get humans bigger
stronger professionally tend to be
incredibly understanding of
inter-individual differences because
when you've worked with hundreds of
people you see like Oh some people look
at weights and put on 20 pounds of
muscle and get way stronger and some
people are as consistent and as
hard-working as you could ever hope that
they would be and you know every five
pound PR as it calls for a massive
celebration because it took for like
four months to get there and they still
only bench like 185 like you see both
ends of that spectrum and when I was
like young and confident and obviously
quite gifted for lifting I thought that
I was making better games than everyone
else just because I was so much smarter
than them and training so much harder
than them and then when I actually
started coaching people I realize like
oh I'm full of [ __ ] people just respond
to training differently and and I mean
like you can all that's also hammered
home if you read research and understand
how variance works but I mean the the
thing that did it primarily for me is
just actually training people and seen
that firsthand and then kind of along
with that kind of a meta shift that has
happened for me is just the strength of
my takes in general has generally gotten
a lot
weaker so it's I mean I used to be I
used to be one to pretty confidently
proclaim like you know X is better than
Y and for these physiological reasons
and like that's just how it is bro and
these days I'm much more willing to say
like you know when you look at the
research it seems like this is better
than that on average under these
circumstances these may be some of the
underlying mechanisms but there's a lot
we don't know yet and inter-individual
differences are such that you know maybe
this isn't the best thing for everyone
but it's at least a good starting point
which is not as it doesn't make for good
sound bites but I think it's probably a
more intellectually rigorous and honest
way to approach things
so like I'm I mean I think if you asked
me five years from now what things did
you use to you know have really strong
takes on that you've done a complete 180
on I don't know that I'll be able to
come up with anything because I don't
know that I have that many strong takes
other than stuff that's basically
completely obvious like you know hey the
first law of thermodynamics exists if
you want to get big you should probably
eat a fair amount of protein I mean just
the things that I believe strongly are
things that I would be horrendously
shocked if they turned out to be false
and now it's just kind of I have
opinions that lean one way or another
that I don't hold incredibly strongly
for the most part I'm very interested
that this is one of yours because if
anything I've been working on moving the
opposite direction so I think because
most of my writing for the last six
years or so has been purely academic for
journals it's like if you put a
statement in a research paper it's
almost like it's viewed from a different
perspective like if I if I read
something
a lay press article about fitness I look
at it and I say under what conditions
might that statement be true mm-hmm I
try to be kind of charitable with it but
in like the peer-reviewed academic
setting if you make a statement I feel
like people view it as is there a
condition in which that's not true
mm-hmm and in that case they said you
got to get that out of your paper mm-hmm
like that statements not right you have
to remove it from the paper or put like
17 qualify right yeah and so what I've
what I realized when I first kind of got
back into non academic writing was I
need to stop having 19 caveats for every
statement I say like there's a middle
ground mm-hmm and so I think it's
interesting that I think we're both
working our way toward that comfortable
middle ground yeah yeah like just
because we come from opposite sides of
that the background yeah like I used to
have a lot of hot takes and you used to
have only cold takes freezing cold and
and now we're both kind of working
towards like lukewarm like
room-temperature takes yeah but no I
mean honestly like if you put something
in a research paper that under some
context could be falsified you have to
fix it mm-hmm you have to put a million
caveats or just punt and say I'd never
mind
so yeah I'm trying to increase the the
heat index of my tags and your I think
you're already there though I think I
think the stuff I've seen from you the
last few years has been oh no it's
pretty new it's gotten a lot better yeah
I mean I think you're referring to years
ago yeah when I when I go back and read
the stuff that I wrote anything from
like mid 2015 to like early 2016 on
there there may be a little thing here
or there that I kind of disagree with
but for the most part I'm like yeah yeah
this this is still pretty good it holds
up it's a lot of stuff prior to that I'm
not not the most proud of yeah and me
and that's one of the things I'm I guess
I'm kind of worried about for
up-and-coming fitness pros these days
cuz I feel like I mean back in the day
like Facebook existed and I think
Instagram was there but it wasn't big
yet and for the most part like if people
were putting takes out into the world it
was mostly blogging and then sharing
that the link to their blog on Facebook
and so if you weren't connected to many
people if you had like a super hot take
that turned out to be a super bad take
maybe a dozen people would come in
contact with it and I had a bunch of
those but though they never stuck right
because like I by the time my audience
started growing I'd kind of learned
better and had went back and either like
changed those articles tremendously or
hid them and these days with just the
way social media works I feel like one
bad take can get you know blasted to
tens or hundreds of thousands of people
and you know maybe it's because
someone's a charlatan and they're trying
to swindle folks or maybe someone is a
good faith actor they just don't know
that much they're inexperienced but then
the next time someone sees their name
it's like oh I remember that guy he said
some really stupid [ __ ] that one time oh
it's it's Greg they go home and inject
your piss guys yeah I don't listen to
him so yeah I I worry about I mean
nothing's ever truly gone on the
internet but I think it used to be
easier to forget things on the internet
than it is now and say yeah I mean
coming up in the fitness space in 2012
versus 2019 I think it's a completely
different world out there on social
media and and I do I do wonder so kind
of to take a step back from this
question like what have you changed your
mind about I think another kind of
general meta question is how easy is it
to change your mind and I think it's it
makes it way harder to change your mind
if you are someone who has a very
well-known
hard public stand on a particular topic
because then there will be a lot of
people who you know very much agree with
you that about whatever this particular
take is and if you change your mind you
risk pissing them off there's gonna be a
lot of folks who don't exercise the
principle of charity and think that you
know this thing you said that was wrong
you knew it was wrong and you were just
trying to lie to folks even if that's
very much not the case and so then if
you change your mind how accepting are
they going to be or do they think it's
just a start of a new grift and I think
that just the more the more
interconnected people are and the more
just aggressive people are in general
the harder it makes it to change your
mind and I do think I do think that
that's generally heading in the wrong
direction
overall I agree all right so next
segment is a fan favorite we've been
going back and forth
everybody knows Greg and I both like to
spend some time in the kitchen a lot of
my recipes tend to be pretty macro
friendly but this time Greg actually has
a recipe that is also pretty macro
friendly so I don't want to give it away
but Greg go ahead and take it away with
recipe time yes so this is less of just
one fixed recipe and more of just a
general recommendation and that is if
you're looking for something that can
have really really good macros while
also being really flavorful and very low
maintenance is I think people sleep on
stews too much and I think people do
that because stews tend to not be
incredibly macro friendly so like a
chicken stew might be cream based which
obviously isn't macro friendly at all
unless maybe you're doing a traditional
keto diet beef stew you tend to use a
fattier cut of beef like short rib or
maybe chuck again pretty fatty so macros
aren't going to be good
but if you use lean meat in a stew and
just add extra flavoring stuff to kind
of compensate for that it still turns
out quite well so what I am eating this
week is a beef stew and like I said
generally if I was making beef stew and
I was just trying to make it as
delicious as possible I would probably
use chuck about 20% fat fat helps lock
in flavor a lot of the delicious flavor
compounds in food are fat soluble so if
you have more fat it helps you gain and
retain more flavor but this month or
this week what I did my meal prep with
is London broil which is very very lean
it's like 96% lean something like that
and it's the type of thing where it's
around as lean as I round but I mean I
around is just garbage London broil is
actually pretty good meat but it's it's
one of those things where it has so
little fat that by itself it's not gonna
be that flavorful if you just try to
make roast beef with it but you can
throw it in a stew gives you a ton of
protein if you have enough of it it
still imparts a good beef flavor so if
you want to Jack my recipe this week how
I made my stew it was 800 grams of
carrots 600 grams of celery 900 grams of
onions so that's kind of the basics that
would be a at the heart of an American
or I believe also French style beef stew
to kind of add some more savory notes
and ramp up the beefy flavor I also put
in about 750 or 800 grams of mushrooms
and a ton of garlic because garlic is
fantastic then I used about five pounds
or about 2.25 kilograms of London broil
to thicken up the stew I used half a cup
of flour so if you're if you have celiac
or you're gluten intolerant there's
probably other things you can use but
I mean traditionally you just use flour
and so this this I will note was a
big-ass pot of stew and it only took
half a cup of flour so like per Bowl not
very much but flours super absorbent so
you don't need that much to thicken it
three liters of beef stock so generally
I would make my own but I just bought
some from the store so like it had
collagen in it but no fat no carbs and
then really just whatever herbs you
would like for more flavor so I went
with rosemary thyme and marjoram but you
can really do whatever you want and so
and then just salt and pepper to taste I
would recommend salting early in the
process and putting in less salt than
you think you would need just because as
it cooks down the salt will concentrate
and so if you get it as salty as you
want before it simmers down its going to
wind up incredibly salty and as
something that's kind of optional you
will get more flavor in the finished
product if you sear the meat beforehand
but so it it kind of depends how
obsessive you want to be with stew for
health reasons so there's some evidence
that using high heat cooking methods on
proteins will create compounds that can
like promote oxidative stress in your
body maybe decrease insulin sensitivity
a little bit and so just generally for
if you wanted to consume meat as
healthily as possible you would go with
low temperature cooking methods so for
more flavor sear the beef if you're just
doing this to be super healthy you don't
have to sear it it'll be a little less
flavorful but it'll still be good and so
essentially you just take all of that
you throw it in a pot this is the low
effort version the high effort version
is you might want a time when you put
the vegetables in because you know like
carrots take a long time to cook
thoroughly
onions don't so if you throw it all in
it once some of the vegetables will turn
to mush I personally like that if you
want to tin the stew more though you can
kind of time when you put the vegetables
in but I just threw it all in at once
and then I mean just basically check
back on it every hour or so keep it at a
low simmer and give it a stir and once
the like soup or like stew sauce I guess
I guess it's almost a gravy
once it's as thick as you want your stew
is done and so the macros for the beef
stew I made per Bowl is 68 grams of
protein 23 grams of carbs and 13 grams
of fat which I mean those are tremendous
macros the difference between this beef
stew and a beef stew that I would make
normally is just the stuff that add adds
flavor I put more of it in so more
onions than normal more garlic than
normal the fresh herbs I put in I put
like twice as much of those in as I
typically would just because this is a
lower fat product and so it's not going
to be quite as good for holding on to
flavor so you have to add extra flavor
to compensate but you can't compensate
and it still has a pretty good mouthfeel
like the flour does good work for thick
thickening it up and making it feel like
a rich product without having to have
all of the fat so if you've never tried
if you've never tried like to make macro
friendly super stew I would strongly
recommend it it's not that hard like
really as long as you go with fibrous
vegetables and lean meat it's hard to go
wrong the macros are gonna come out
pretty good
beef stew is a good thing it's a good
option to start with just because beef
stews are inherently so flavorful that
if what you make ends up being off the
mark a little bit it will still taste
good it's a good option for meal prep
because you can make a big ass pot it'll
last you the whole week and it's
incredibly low effort you could make it
in a slope
as well but it I mean you're basically
just throwing all the stuff in there
walking away and you know just killing
the heat when when it's done and also if
you're on a diet you're trying to cut
you know you're not just eating macro
friendly stuff for the fun of it soups
and stews are really good for inducing
satiety on a per calorie basis just
because there's a lot of extra like
semi-thick liquid in them one it helps
fill up your stomach more and it also
delays gastric gastric emptying so it
helps kind of on a like I said on a per
calorie basis it helps improve satiety
so a good study to check out on that
general topic it's called soups increase
satiety through delayed gastric emptying
yet increased glycemic response but I
mean there's there's actually a somewhat
sizable body of literature on soups and
stews so that's just one example but
yeah so shared a recipe but I would
strongly recommend the general concept
of if you want something low effort
that's gonna fill you up and have a lot
of flavor soups and stews can be very
macro friendly and I think are are very
slept on see a lot of pictures on social
media of people you know eating fish or
chicken or lean meat or whatever like on
a plate but you don't see that many
soups and stews it's good it's good [ __ ]
it's easy it's healthy I would recommend
it the question that I think a lot of
people are wondering is how much weight
does your recommendation carry and I
think this weekend we're gonna find out
a lot about that because this weekend we
are having a lasagna cook-off now this
is not open to the public do not show up
at Greg's house but this weekend we will
be having lasagna cook-off it will be
Greg's lasagna versus mine and we will
be putting them head-to-head
and we'll probably have two different
ranking systems one would be an overall
subjective quality ranking the other
will be scaled to a per calorie ranking
and I'm aiming for a sweet I think my
lasagnas gonna check both if I'm being
honest I've got a lot of very good very
good feedback from people out there on
Instagram that have have tried my recipe
they loved it they've made some little
variations which I don't condone but at
least they're at least they're in the
ballpark so dear listener if this gives
you any idea of how badly Eric is going
to get defeated in this lasagna cook-off
his girlfriend is actually team Greg on
this one we're gonna meet up beforehand
to make noodles make beautiful lasagnas
Eric is going to is that for real yes
when did this conversation happen I
don't remember any this is the first
I've heard of this so just as some more
context Eric's girlfriend is also really
into cooking so Eric maybe like a month
ago we generally discussed like
challenging dishes we had made before
and things that we would like to try it
some point and one of the things fairly
high on both of our lists is we had
never made noodles and so you can get
like a pasta roller but in it'll have
like cutting attachments that seems like
a lot of work so I think and it's also
just something else you have to buy so I
think lasagna is a good thing to start
with
just because after you make the noodles
you just kind of have to roll them flat
and don't have to worry about cutting
them uniformly so yeah we we chatted
about this on messenger like two days
ago
she's she's coming over early we're
making noodles so we're gonna have
beautiful fresh homemade noodles to go
in a classic traditional lasagna and
you're screwed buddy no that's troubling
for two reasons first of all my
girlfriend is colluding with the enemy
which is really messed up
but more importantly I don't understand
why this misconception continues to
survive but you do not need noodles in a
lasagna I said it time and time again we
got to put that myth to bed and we're
gonna do that this weekend all right now
to play us out if you are in the United
States listening to this which is about
half of you you know that college
football started this week and I've got
ties to the beautiful state of Ohio I'm
a big Ohio State football fan Greg
you're an Ohio State football fan as
well and so what what is our prediction
with Ohio State football this year how
many games are they playing I think if I
think it's 12 in conference and then the
conference championship would be the
13th I believe so 15 and oh baby
15 and oh and then then the playoff hell
yeah so Urban Meyer our old coach is now
on television as a one of the television
people and someone asked him on air the
other day is this Michigan's year and he
very very awesomely seemed extremely
surprised and said you're for what
[Laughter]
that's amazing I mean the the Urban
Meyer ten year has been kind of up and
her was kind of up and down at Ohio
State but the fact that he maintained a
perfect record on Michigan automatically
makes him in the pantheon of Ohio State
coaches yeah up and down in terms of
like there were times where we felt like
we were underperforming yeah but that
was with the assumption that we should
be performing clearly better than like
ninety nine and a half percent of teams
oh yeah we never had a bad year with him
it was just like oh we should have been
excellent
correct if you're listening abroad
college football is huge in America we
love it American football in general it
is slower than most sports most of it is
spent waiting
you usually acquire brain damage which
is now a whole field of literature is
the football concussion literature so if
you're listening abroad and you just
don't get it
you're not wrong necessarily but college
football is awesome and if you can
struggle through it learn the rules and
develop the patience for a sport that is
80% waiting around it is worth it
because oh my god is fun to watch yeah
and and I really do think Ohio State's
gonna be good this year just looking at
how well the offense did with Ryan de
calling the plays last year I think I
think urban had a good defensive mind
obviously I think he was an offensive
innovator back in the day at Florida but
I think people largely caught up with
him and I obviously think he was a
tremendous recruiter but I think I think
the offense is going to be something to
behold this year and that it's it's
gonna be it's gonna be a good year up in
Columbus yeah I mean new quarterback new
head coach new defensive coordinator
there should be a lot of surprises but
definitely the expectation is I mean
quite high and I think preseason they're
ranked in the top five or six by some of
the polls no I don't know but but
they're up there and we are stoked
so go bucs everybody enjoy it and let's
keep our fingers crossed I know Ohio
State has they've they were in the news
trying to get the word be trademarked so
let's hope that everything's going well
in the courtroom there what were they
really I think so that's incredible it's
awesome so we're gonna keep them in our
thoughts and hopefully the the lawyers
are going to come out on top that's like
that's like that drama on YouTube a few
years ago when some big channel was
trying to trademark the word react yeah
it was like one of those things like the
kids react videos or whatever where it's
like kids listen to old music or like
watch old TV shows yeah they were trying
to trademark react and people thought
that that was over the top which I kind
of agree but Ohio State trademarking in
Article V I think it's fitting I don't
think that's a reach I don't think so
alright thank you so much for listening
for the next half of this podcast we've
got an interview with Lee Peele
is one of the internet evidence-based
fitness oh geez I mean she's been at the
forefront of that game for years and
years and years we had the pleasure of
hanging out with her in Kansas City at
the Fitness Summit this year and while
we were there we said hey you ought to
come on the podcast and fortunately she
did
now we recorded this interview what
feels like seven or eight years ago so I
don't think we made any particularly
outdated references but if we did give
us the benefit of the doubt but we hope
you'll enjoy that interview which will
be coming after the music
[Music]
[Music]
all right welcome to the stronger by
science podcast this is Eric Trexler I'm
here with Greg knuckles and today we are
joined by Lee peel Lee thank you so much
for joining us got you guys's voices
really are soothing they are very
soothing that's that's why people come
we really don't talk about anything
particularly informative it's just kind
of it's like I used to watch Bob Ross a
lot you know the the painter our happy
trees yeah absolutely I'll you know I
wasn't that into painting but it was
just so so soothing no I really believe
he was some sort of weird PBS form of
meditation for a lot of people did you
did you know that his son is carrying on
the mantle I did not the Ross name will
never die
Oh the son is also going to be painting
happy trees that's your most the
greatest news yeah now Lee like I said
it it's very nice of you to join us now
the three of us you me and Greg we hung
out a little bit in Kansas City at the
fitness summit this year yeah and I
didn't realize honestly the presence
that I was in I mean obviously I knew it
with Greg because it's a given but I
didn't even realize the amazing presence
that I was in with you Eric right and
I'm so you know Greg and I we thought
that that we all had a good time so you
know Greg and I every Sunday night we
have kind of it's kind of a pillar in
our community we have a weekly Sunday
night dinner it's really important to me
and Greg and our families and we
extended an invitation to you and we
said why don't you come by for Sunday
dinner and at that time you were very
very busy and then we extend the podcast
invitation and all of a sudden the
schedule opens up so I guess the first
question for the podcast would be would
you like to explain yourself well first
of all let's just not a lot of time is
passed between now and Casey and second
of all it's really stressful trying to
plan macro relevant casserole dishes for
a large group of people it's very
intimidating you don't know the pressure
that I've had on my end I've been going
through recipe books I
I've been trying to organize whether or
not that I do layered dishes separate
the dishes then there's just general
conversation you know trying to prep and
plan that doing background research
making sure that I can you know suck up
to all the women there because they're
the ones that are really important who
said anything about macro friendly you
know what's funny is I swear that
someone I thought it was you Greg that
you man it's funny if you're being
sarcastic but I I talked about the fact
that I was vegetarian and you said
something about the fact well there's
you know plenty of different like Macker
there you made some sort of comment
about there being macorís and i thought
oh my god did they like and you've said
something about meal prep now it's like
kind of like meal prep for the week or
something
and I thought oh did they actually
really break down their cookout
gathering into like different Macker and
do I need to know the macro content of
the food that I bring because that's
some next-level like next-level potluck
going on there which knows so the the
way it typically works is people do use
it further their meal prep for the week
so mostly like people just bring a bunch
of meat we throw it on the grill and
then people will have a portion of the
meat that was thrown on the grill and
then we we all just either like make or
bring whatever else we feel like eating
since this past week was Memorial Day
like I made a big ol pan full of sliders
so it was like burgers and barbecue pork
and buffalo chicken with like homemade
yeast rolls and then we made an apple
pie and there was ice cream for it and
it was tremendous but no we if our meals
do turn out macro friendly that is
purely by accident so is this more of
the dry Greg kind of sarcasm that I
might have taken a bit seriously in the
moment is it a chance that that happened
because I have a feeling that that
happens a lot with you Greg that you
might say something and it dries you
don't manner
people are taking it seriously I just
don't think I would even joke about that
yeah it seems very out of character yeah
you just couldn't be further from the
truth when it comes I mean it's just in
terms of macros its debauchery
absolutely shameful what happens on
Sunday nights I mean most people felt
ill this past weekend because it was
just it was way too much well no I
really hate I missed it but it but in a
good way
yeah yeah ill in a good way now Lee quit
screwing around we got to get to
business here sure try to focus I'm
sorry sorry sorry so Lee peel you are an
author you've written a lot of things on
your about me on your website you you
say that you're a layman researcher so
what what is your kind of operational
definition what is a layman researcher
yeah the majority of my time is really
spent in literature review right I just
I spend a lot of time reading other
people's research I spend a lot of my
time going through and really what you
were discussing really collecting data
from both sides of the fence a lot of my
time is spent siphoning through really
anything I can get my hands on and and
trying to come to the conclusions and
put things together and and try to help
my audience or help my clients and the
people that I that I aid with trying to
come to some sort of good and educated
conclusions and and occasionally
occasionally trying to contribute to the
field and in a really positive way and
and maybe make a make a change here
there but I like to make sure that I
make it very clear that I try not to
operate outside of my scope very you
know very much and I really like
collecting data and and running through
the data and doing things like that and
just trying to come to some conclusions
but it is very I will say how can I put
this I don't know if amateur is the is
the right it's not formal it's not
formal and sits it's not a formal way of
doing things or at least not at this
time well you've certainly made your
mark on the industry which includes but
as
limited to your books so your first book
when did that one come out the first one
well the initial release of it it
started off as a sticky post in you know
in a weight loss forum that's kind of
how it got started it started off as a
sticky post and it was kind of
troubleshooting oh you're not losing fat
like you're having a problem losing fat
and this was kind of the dawn of the
internet but it was at the peak of this
is before Facebook was it was only still
kind of college-bound and it wasn't for
everyone so message boards were very
much a big thing you know and it was a
it was a manner in which a lot of people
collected their information so from
bouncing around to the bodybuilding.com
forums or a body recomposition even just
weight loss forums column I think JP
Fitness all of those that there were
certain stickies that I had and I would
kind of update so stickies and then
people would say oh you know you should
should do like a little ebook or
something like that and I had a lot of
friends in the industry that were very
very big on the releasing of ebooks and
new products and stuff like that and and
they were kind of they understood how
that worked and so I released the fat
loss troubleshoot I think the first one
I want to say it was 2007 2008 somewhere
in that area it was horrible
innocent of any sort of grammatical
writing or layout or structure anything
I think I charged nine dollars for it or
something like that and over the years
it's gone through a few editions it's on
its fifth edition right now and it
didn't it I'm gonna be releasing further
but yeah it's it you know it's it's
really in my in my opinion it's it's
really gone through a lot of great
development over the years because it's
really travelled with the breadth and
the girth of my knowledge both as a
writer thank God and as as an educator
and as a learner in this field yeah so
and before you got into that I assume
that you were like coaching and training
people as well I was I was you know I
hubris of youth I definitely jumped into
I was one of those individuals that I
sort of jumped into too
my job and teaching at the exact same
time versus it's taking a step back and
being like oh let me apply this stuff
for many many years and then share my
knowledge upon you
why souls but you never think I jest I
was filled with a lot of zest and there
are things wrong on the people are wrong
on the internet I am I was a walking
version of that terrible me and and and
so I was training people I was working
with people in person at a local gym the
way that that particular gym work is
kind of like a booth gym you pay for a
spot in it and you pay for the ability
to be able to use the gym and then you
can kind of do whatever you want you can
work from 5:00 in the morning to you
know 12 at night because it was even a
24/7 gym but you couldn't have clients
and after 12 and um so yeah I worked
night and day at that gym I took on
anyone I could from Craigslist from my
friends from the colleagues you name it
I took on every single client I could I
worked with people online and I
basically just obsessively compulsive a
solid three years before I ever really
took a break and started writing down or
kind of communicating any of that
information to people but I'm still kind
of always on the message boards you're
one of those trainers that kind of made
the transition from relying on intuition
and anecdote and kind of the hands-on
stuff and made that transition and said
what if I peruse the research literature
and start looking there for answers so
and then eventually relaying that to
others but what what was kind of the
impetus for transitioning from you know
a lot of people think all the
information all ever need I can observe
in the gym what what made you make that
transition into becoming a layman
researcher I think one of the instances
that really drove it was ultimately
problems you know my clients are having
problems it's not it's not point-shoot
do you know I ran into a position in
which that I tried to achieve what I
wanted to achieve with my body
composition and outside of a few areas
of hiccups in the early stages of it I
did not really run into any problems it
was kind
all the general calculators work for me
you know all of the general protocol
worked for me for me it was working fine
and for a large subset of my initial
clients it was working fine it was kind
of that jackpot lot of everything coming
together and working great but then then
you start to notice the clients in which
that gaps fall through and there are
issues be it with adherence or with some
sort of issue of you know stress or
overtraining or at the time you know I
owe is it is it starvation mode or
metabolic adaptation or you know what
are what are the issues here why are
things not kind of working together and
it's kind of it was kind of that issue
of oh you know things aren't so black
and white I'm starting to see more of
the grey and nuance of things and I
think that that's really true with any
one who gets into any sort of field in
which that they start to get into a
specialization of it they see oh okay
there's always a lot more nuance and
it's always a lot more murky and
complicated than these things so
problems essentially adherence problems
were an issue you know success problems
with linear fat loss or weight loss or
linear muscle gain
basically anything that stopped being
predictable started going down that
route and luckily for me I was
associated with a lot of people who at
at that time we're knee-deep
they were either professors or doctors
or in the industry as researchers or
there's obsessive-compulsive people that
really like PubMed and the combination
of those things opened up that gate for
me and I always joke and say that bro
science taught me science because it was
a it was a great entryway into into the
world of research and and in to some
degree academia that previously to me
had not been something that I explored
yeah it seems to be a common thread of
people that once you've done it long
enough and you start running into
problems that are difficult to explain
and there's just a ton of conflicting
anecdote it's almost like the natural
kind of extension of that is where can I
find some objective assessment of this
or some quantification of it and it kind
of Shepherds people toward you know
becoming one of those very obsessive
PubMed people you know yeah and and it's
also in that moment too that you're
trying to trying to live beyond the
anecdote you know and and I wasn't in a
situation in which that I could lab rat
trap people you know I I and at the time
yeah I got I got started kind of right
at the initial entry of things like you
know fitness trackers and and body wear
devices and things like that and they're
ultimately with all of my work and
wherever my work when it was kind of
okay what can i how can I apply this how
is this applicable to my situation in
which that that I'm using and and I
would try to you know if if a client was
upset about say oh you know wait
trending and she really was being
diligent but her wait trend or her
linear trend was off you know what were
the explanations for these things and a
lot of the times it was finding at least
some sort of minor explanation or
Association of you know this is why this
is happening this is why this takes
place you know food food weight for
example was just such a big one you know
the return to maintenance weight and and
and saying it at a certain maintenance
weight and when you drop into a deficit
how you lose you lose certain amount of
glycogen you lose a certain amount of
food weight and things like that but
just even things like that and
understanding I explaining to my clients
this is what's happening when you're
trying to lose body fat for example um
these are the things that you're going
to lose and the initial of a deficit
just from eating list just from these
factors taking place certain things can
take place this is what can make it jump
back up this is what can make you know
kind of having the answer to that really
annoying why kid and I was the annoying
white kid but being able to answer
there's questions in my opinion really
helped with the psychology of my clients
and it really helped with the psychology
of their adherence and getting through
their stop points and I'm not saying
that they're you know are aren't always
kind of more difficult cases but finding
the answers to some of those questions
and utilizing you know science and
biology and and how we kind of get there
so to speak or how the body gets there
during these processes I
found to be huge for the ability to talk
to my clients and that helped ease them
through transitions of things and to
feel safe and you know in in knowledge
we have safety
I truly believe education is a key to
feeling safe from emotional distress
yeah you mentioned earlier a couple
terms came up metabolic adaptation in
starvation mode and you also mentioned
you know one of the big problems you see
or that the questions that would kind of
fall on your lap as a coach or stalls
and weight loss and confusion about them
so you you've written a lot about
metabolic adaptation and starvation mode
is that just because you it became such
a common question in practice yeah you
know it somewhere around and this was
more online that this was driven from
because I as I said I was taking online
clients during a small amount but at
working with online people as well and I
kept getting these messages and I think
that this is a very particular note to
note that I was getting messages and
working with people that were coming out
of contests prep or that were really
really driven to their goals really
driven to trying to achieve their goals
at you know to some degree and their
wants are saying like at any cost and
there was a very particular subset of
audience that kind of was matriculating
towards my direction and tour some of
the other people in the industry at that
x direction and I'm not gonna name any
specific names but there are certain
people or you know who now are leaders
or people that kind of understand this
aspect of the thing and their
girlfriends were having problems and
they're like I don't understand you know
like I I'm a I'm a coach or I know what
I'm doing and so I started supplying
body bugs and sending them out to people
and we would start tracking data you
know we start tracking steps and then
and what ultimately a lot of the problem
was and you know Taconic the spoiler a
lot of the problem was was basic
metabolic adaptations that combined with
to some degree you know some level of
poor food monitoring or intermittent
periods of ever feeding that would you
know can't
things out and then also just a general
if you will over conditioning be it
increases microcon general efficiency or
you know what have you but the
collection of all of these kind of
anomalies coming together to kind of
make the answer to our problems but at
the time at the time even in a lot of
the main nutrition literature you saw
things like starvation mode I mean this
is even in textbooks and some textbooks
that we read we saw things about like
starvation mode or if you go into a
deficit you you eat too little for a
period of time or what-have-you your
body's gonna shut down and quote-unquote
stop for stop burning fat or stop
releasing fat and so there was this kind
of hyper ability and there was a moment
there if you will at least in my just in
my circle of the internet and in my
circle of kind of the people that we
were communicating and and we even had a
sub forum in in a popular internet place
we had we had a secret it was a hidden
sub forum that we would kind of put
information or deliver information or
things that we kind of found out and it
was solving this problem and and what we
kind of ended up you know seeing and
learning through that was obviously some
research that's been around for a long
time
kind of came to a head and and you know
discussing things like leptin or you
know the issues with thyroid health and
things like that issues would decrease
our resting metabolic rate our REE and
things like that all those things kind
of you know yes those made senses but
there was also the issue and and what we
found to be more the case was to have to
do with you know low-grade activity
being just as important as exercise
activity and all of these things kind of
coming together to explain how yes you
can be metabolically not at your most
high level but a lot of it also has to
just do with efficiency you know
efficiency and the body trying to do
what it can and you being intelligent
enough to not drive too hard to take
breaks when needed and ultimately to
adjust when need be for decreases that
are going to happen when anyone diets
and and not try to drive yourself too
hard for things that don't have to
happen if you will
so it was I think it was a great time to
you know from just a communication since
and kind of you know discovering thing
but also from that was born a lot of
mistakes as well and assumptions about
things but I I think I saw the the
industry in general rally around really
solid answers and information for these
these problems as they came about and
then of course it really at the next
level when your paper got released and
everything else has kind of followed
through so it was I it was a really
great time to kind of see it happening
but there were the big core problems
with a specific subset of audience that
was really having a hard time
quote-unquote losing weight regardless
of the training or no matter what it was
they were doing I just like to draw
attention to kind of like the
meta-narrative your your weaving right
now because I think something that's
lost on the damn kids these days we're
getting into fitness stuff now is like
if you're if you're like you know 19 20
you're you're getting into fitness you
find like quote-unquote evidence-based
fitness stuff there's a lot of stuff
within our community now that everyone
just kind of accepts as fact and is
taken as almost obviously true
but what people don't realize and this
is basically the story you just told is
like it wasn't that way ten years ago
now or really even five years ago now
and it took a lot of work from a lot of
people to you know spend like weeks in
PubMed just like digging up obscure
references that you know maybe if you
had a PhD in nutrition and like it was
your job to know all of that stuff you
would know but like as layman you you
don't really know that and so it takes
like this gargantuan effort for people
to accumulate all of this research and
synthesize it and get a coherent picture
out of it make sense of it say like hey
here's what the research is kind of
saying and then bros on bodybuilding
forums to say like oh no this is
[ __ ]
so then once you have the information
then it's like another multi-year war
for the hearts and minds and now like
the perspective kind of wins out but
[ __ ] kids these days see any of that
so they're they're like ungrateful and
it's like oh well of course that's how
it is like why why would anyone be dumb
enough to think otherwise and it's like
hey you kids you don't know how good you
have it I you know I tried to not to cry
and my violin soup about that but
sometimes I really do him like you damn
kids shaking my fist get off my lawn
that it really is true it there's
there's so much of what I remember when
I was being a part of even even little
things now that are just commonplace
like sure yeah yeah neat you adapt you
know your body as a lowering of movement
it was a big thing when we were saying
things like that or talking about things
like that and it was it was really
challenged and it was during a time and
people you know there was a big wave of
hit you know the the high intensity
interval you know training's thing that
was when I came onto the scene that was
like insane paleo was kind of starting
to get going as well and there was just
all this like basically do everything
you can to be and I'm the saying that
doesn't still exists obviously Quito is
kind of the the new thing right now but
there's all this intensity and focus on
how hard can you possibly work and drive
yourself into the ground and and you
know I I never really understood over
conditioning and this was kind of off
the gate and and I don't I don't know if
it was just didn't make sense to me but
I never really understood
let's condition ourselves until we we
break and we have the most insane
metabolic efficiency and then say that
our metabolic rate is going to be even
ramped up and higher didn't really make
sense to me because to me in my mind I
was like well aren't you what you what
you're really doing isn't aren't you
making yourself more efficient and
aren't you making yourself in better
shape so that you know when you walk to
the mailbox you feel better when you
take your stairs you it's easier and
wouldn't that to some degree equate to
kind of a less overall caloric burn not
that there's anything wrong with that
but there is all these
answers if you will are these kind of
challenges and claims coming even from
somewhat of a scientific world that
we're saying we're gonna ramp up your
metabolic rate and we're gonna reset
your metabolism and we're gonna do all
these things and there were some of it
that left my head scratching just from a
even when I wasn't conformed informed at
all about it where I was like I don't
really know if that makes a lot of sense
I'm not entirely sure that makes a lot
of sense but okay and then it was in the
textbooks you know a lot of it was in
the textbooks and that's not to say that
you know people that work to put things
in the textbooks I've even you know
minored lead contribute a quote here or
there and I'm so proud to be remotely a
part of any of it so I don't say that's
knock it but it's it's it takes a lot of
work and I feel it always is kind of you
know a few years back and then it gets
there and then it becomes accepted and I
mean isn't that kind of the truth too
and a lot of areas of life it's
obviously not sure in the fitness
industry but it takes a lot of work to
get people to kind of be okay and shake
their heads to be like ya know okay that
makes sense everyone saying that's
making sense now everyone's okay with
that there's not just a bunch of
contrarian for the sake of being
contrarian or people that have an agenda
she had to fight all of that you know
you have to fight all that with with
what you're saying you have to fight
people that have a monetary agenda you
have to fight people who are afraid I
mean look at it with vaccines for
example it's a great example you have to
fight all these kinds of people with
everything that's going through and I I
think that people forget that sometimes
it's the people and I'm not trying to
say that it's just myself but sometimes
it's the people in the background being
like yeah but look at this evidence and
then someone who's more taken seriously
says no but really look at this evidence
and then somebody else who has a bigger
audience says no but really look at this
evidence and then it becomes this
collective well yeah God guys duh and
then you make you kind of want to punch
the body in the face but I'm gonna say
like is there basically like a magic
5-minute window and if something goes
from being like largely rejected and
then for five minutes it's like I accept
that and it's a good point and then five
minutes after it's like yeah no [ __ ]
everybody yeah I always find myself
being stuck on the wrong side of that
window man and it makes me hate myself
in life sometimes I think the example of
that that I remember the most vividly is
the whole like clean eating thing yeah
so I remember like the the first article
that like really kicked it off is Alan
Aragon wrote a piece for wanna be big
calm back when that was like oh wanna be
big was great so that kind of like
kicked it off and then there were like
four or five like copycat pieces and
then army leg he wrote like a fifteen or
twenty thousand word article going
through just like an ass load of studies
on like food quality and different
macronutrient compositions and whatnot
yeah it felt like what the Rux again
there to you I mean he touch at all dude
that kind of like sixty thousand shares
on social media or something outrageous
yeah and then after that it just kind of
became accepted fact and if anything the
pendulum at that point swung way far
potato woulda just hopped arts yeah yeah
yeah but yeah like like that was the
progression and like when armies article
dropped that was like the end of clean
eating at least for like several years
yeah yeah because after that the the if
it's in your macro stuff really took off
and people were happily and boasting ly
on their Instagram instead of it being
oh look how amazingly I made a piece of
broccoli look and taste it was look I'm
having a pop-tart for post-workout and
you know it like in it and it took that
turn
yeah and it's from a sociological
standpoint fascinating to watch but
sometimes when you're in it you know
it's uh and then like immediately after
armies article I saw another like three
dozen copycat articles and all of the
comments on them we're like well no [ __ ]
everyone knows it's like dear commenter
you didn't know this until two weeks ago
like get down off your high horse no I I
feel like it's always that um it's the
it's the ex-smoker
effect I always call it yeah because
everyone I know who used to be a smoker
you know it's like all smoking is
disgusting I can't even believe
something was like you used to smoke
like a pack a day and it's like
well I wouldn't know and it's okay all
right that's fine good for you maybe
maybe think about the people that are
there you know before and after but yeah
it's it's it's it's interesting to watch
from a sociological aspect it can be
somewhat frustrating to watch when I I
think when you're really trying to get
something out there about change and
really really are trying to help the
narrative of people and trying to help
people steer in the right direction you
know guide away from this information
and stuff like that and sometimes I find
myself just being like I can't wait for
another one of those big articles to
kind of come so that people are like oh
there you go and and I try
narcissistically not to think I will it
has to be your article or you know or
has to be your contribution just because
you know something doesn't mean
everybody else needs to know or you know
you know it but it is it it is one of
those kinds of things to watch when
you've been in it so long I think it's
you see these trends happen and it's
fascinating to watch the trends I think
it's very telling and I hope that it'll
help my work it seems to have these past
few years yeah so one of these topics
that's been you know as we mentioned
kind of there's a lot of back-and-forth
now I think a lot of people are
generally on board with it but coming
back to metabolic adaptation you wrote a
book called starve mode now when someone
asks you is starvation mode real how do
you answer that question I you know I
say theoretically the concept of what a
lot of people think starvation mode was
was just the body of dapping or kind of
you know somewhat shutting down or
altering certain processes it does does
there have an app temptation I mean that
honestly this is how I always kind of
explain them like is there an app tap
tation and technically if you wanted to
quibble over the fact that there's a
mode that we go into and we eat less
food yeah I mean I guess to some degree
there's a bit of a linguistics truth to
that right but what I always explain to
people is and one of the things that
I've always said is that in order to
lose body fat you have to reach
metabolic adaptation which is I think a
lot of people don't really think about
it like that
but in order to access body fat loss you
you kind of you have to have a drop in
certain things you have to you have to
pull from fat stores you have to have
alterations in certain hormones you have
to have things take place the body has
to know that it needs to utilize fat as
fuel to some degree and aggressive
metabolic adaptation extreme lowering of
or alterations of your you know resting
metabolic rate which you know even when
we look at and you obviously know this
so meet saying any of this right now
assets that I'm saying anything to Eric
by the way I'm more suited to the
audience and versus Eric but a lot less
than you think and I I know way less but
but all of these you know all of these
things they kind of have to take place
and there can be severe forms of it but
but ultimately you know to some degree
we have to adapt but metabolic
adaptation is kind of you know on at
least some small level even if you're
just looking at just TIFF just just lack
it less food less less food and and
alterations of most people have some
sort of option alteration of
subconscious activity expenditure you
know these things they just happen and
what I tried to explain to them is that
you can you can sit and you can him AHA
about it and and make it an some sort of
horrible event that happens or you can
just understand the associations of
dieting down and are going into a
deficit and and then you you just
respond and you try to do what you can
to make smart decisions to combat the
things that have to take place and
understand those and try not to drive
crazy the other things that don't that
don't have to take place you know
there's I always say there's a degree of
dieting and deficits that's strategy
and what I try to do with my clients is
just try to create the best strategy for
each client and for general speaking I
try to create the best strategy for
generalization and so in the book you
talk about basically what metabolic
adaptation or starvation mode is and
some of these adaptations that take
place and you mentioned to some extent
there they seem to be somewhat
unavoidable but there are instances
where we could definitely exacerbate
those issues so what's your general
approach in terms of like you know
tangible
applicable strategies to try to just
make the best of the situation when
dieting yet generally speaking and I
when I say generally speaking it really
is general generally speaking it really
depends also on the client like I I know
from stalking you a little bit Eric that
you've worked a lot with contest prep
and things like that and let's say I'm
dealing with like a contest for a person
and someone that really goes on and off
seasons or that works within a tighter
schedule the perch for someone like that
is going to be very different than say
the approach for your casual general
housewife or or weekend more your dad or
something like that for all these cliche
titles but it's going to be kind of
different because it's really and I will
say this it's really how much room
they'll give me how how much need to be
at a certain level how fast and how soon
right
so a lot of it has to do with time so my
first aspect of strategy is time how
much time will they give me to do what
it is that we need to achieve if an
individual is really fine with taking a
kind of slower and steady course rain
and they they aren't in any sort of
quick area and and I could get into any
one of details of what strategy I use
for different ones but if an individual
gives me time to do what I need to do
then generally speaking I like to try to
keep my muscle gain and conditioning
anything that has to do with really body
recomposition or performance or have you
on a larger grander scale to be kind of
not a part of fat loss don't get me
wrong there's always lifting if possible
in my programs
there's always muscle maintenance and
always doing what we can to try to get
what we can if you will so I don't want
to try to say that I don't train or we
don't do training but kind of if you
will I tried to only stress what we need
to stress and I try to keep low grade
activity steps or you know moderate
basically nothing above the rpe of five
for a lot of cardio and conditioning I
know that that goes against what a lot
of people do but I find that it really
helps to focus more on
weightlifting for you know keeping it by
atrophy and maybe try and even get a
little gain here there between depending
on where the client has is that in their
beginning to intermediate stage and and
I try to keep low grade activity and
stressors kind of the main component
lots of sleep
lots of watching electrolyte or mineral
replacement very basic things but I try
to do that so that adherence is king and
adherence isn't a problem because you
know if we will if we pull from kind of
this stuff you know even if you look at
studies like the the matador study or
things like that everyone talks about oh
it's that's it's the thing that that
said that metabolic adaptation happens
and that interment at fast instrumented
feeding or what have you and and having
periods of breaks and diet breaks it's
it's it's what we needed to see and
research and you can talk about it like
that and that's great but I also think
that a lot of what these things
highlight is maybe even dietary hearings
that breaks and kind of a more mild
approach to deficit and having breaks
and periods of times in which the body
is not so stressed and you can kind of
just ease in through these things works
really well so in general I try to make
it as pain free as possible I try to
watch for adaptations with neat or more
so Napa non exercise physical activity
because I really separate them between
conscious and subconscious but I try to
make sure that everyone keeps to the
same steps as many variables or not
change as much as possible try to have
it to where I don't do any sort of
extreme macronutrient restrictions I
don't do any extreme you know sodium
restrictions any things like that I
basically try to make it to where the
individual in a deficit as as close as
they are in a weight maintenance with
minor adjustments that need to happen at
the end when they might achieve a lower
body weight depending on how how small
they get from the storm yeah I mean you
mentioned keeping cardio kind of low in
terms of exertion and theoretically
volume I think would that be fair time
yes yes yes so that is somewhat
unpopular but that's also the approach I
take okay so when I the last time I did
a contest prep myself I actually did no
cardio at all
aside from just walking around sometimes
and it was by far the best I ever fell
for sure I think people really
underestimate your ability to beat the
hell out of yourself with high intensity
cardio I mean it can be pretty brutal to
try to get through a prep when you're
doing high intensity interval training
two or three times a week plus you know
all the resistance training on top yeah
now have you heard of what Eric Salazar
is doing Eric Lee I James said the the
weight vest weights and stuff like that
yeah yeah yeah have you seen any of the
stuff they've said about that I I have
and I've I've also tested some stuff
like that with my client clients
weighted vests and and trying to account
for any sort of changes in body weight
you know i i've found on the one hand i
always applaud and I've even done it
myself
so this isn't like some sort of knock or
anything i always applaud trying to eke
out whatever we can dig out in a deficit
you know and trying to make anything as
easy as possible or adding anything we
can to make things go by smoother I've
found hit or miss results in my tracking
of it personally with my clients I've
done it to myself and because for a long
time the majority of any cuts that I did
or any sort of changes in body
composition I did the majority of the
training that I ever did cardio wise was
walking or very low grade endurance you
know kind of we're talking light jogs
maybe like a four so you know it's it's
I can see the I can see the theoretical
of it I can I can see how it could
compensate for for strain I'd love to
see it tested yeah and just to give the
listeners an idea so what he was doing
he's prepping for a bodybuilding
competition and his strategy was instead
of doing a lot of cardio he would make
sure he maintained his normal step count
throughout the entire prep and he would
use a weighted vest to replace the
weight he lost so that he was basically
maintaining the same kind of
basically energy expenditure throughout
the day that could be attributed to just
kind of walking around and living his
normal life so if you're listening and
lost like what are they talking about
that's what he did and his results were
quite good and honestly I just thought
it was cool because it is such a
interesting approach to it not
particularly practical which he did
admit himself but yeah but in
interesting if nothing else I think it's
really important to help people realize
that the non-exercise activity you're
doing is modifiable and has a very big
influence on total energy expenditure I
think that point gets lost on a lot of
people they don't realize like when I
start dieting and I get really lean that
I just stop moving
yes like a lot of people don't recognize
that it was it was literally the
lightning bolt moment that I had when I
started utilizing fitness and activity
trackers it was like oh wait a second
I've been kids at before that time I was
all calculators it was all calculators
you know it was all activity factor
which is pretty much not saying that
activity factor is obsolete there's
there's obviously a use for for for it
but you know I love it is how many weeks
how many days a week ste train it's like
why train six days a week you know
sometimes even seven split training
cardio running etc and I would have I
would have these female clients that
would come in and they would they would
say things like well you know I trained
six seven days a week I eat X amount of
calories I can't lose weight but the
other times if they weren't training
they weren't moving they didn't move so
you can you know just doing one you know
a really good training session every day
for some individuals and the type of
level of lean they want to get and
especially you throw in things like oh
you know and they'd have a lot of
process you know protein powders and and
and bars and stuff like that which isn't
bad but to some degree sometimes you
know you have that versus having like
very hefty Mills with maybe even just
that little bit more ounce of teff and
we're not we're talking minutiae but you
know you throw all that kind of together
and you can really see being off about
active
the factor being off about low-grade
movement and all this kind of stuff and
I've had clients that and this sounds
like such an infomercial catchphrase
kind of thing to say but I have had
clients that have gone into trying to
lose body fat and they really do eat
very higher calories overall than what
they used to be in a deficit but it's
because they've changed and altered
their lifestyle behavior you know they
get consistently quote unquote 10,000
steps a day
they eat kind of more Whole Foods and
care more about cooking and stuff like
that and so to them it it didn't seem
like such a drastic shift even though
yes they were moving more and yes they
were kind of having a more consistent
pace and I think that's something that
people negate to kind of see and it's
it's such an important factor to where
you don't have to have these like
aggressive adaptations but it also
doesn't mean that you're having some
sort of really aggressive Biggest Loser
montage of Jillian Michaels sitting on
your legs and you're gonna be on the
treadmill two hours a day running and
what people kind of see in that regard
there's a middle there's a great middle
it's a great middle I think for health
too I think it's a great middle for
general health if if I can just tell us
an anecdote in here so I am historically
not very successful at cutting which may
come as a big surprise to you guys the
one time that it did go really really
well it was my freshman year of college
and I went into college as a history
major and that basically just involves
like memorizing absurd amounts of
information and so I had read that you
encode memories more efficiently when
you're moving like you don't have to be
moving fast but just like if you're like
trying to learn new vocabulary if you do
it like just as you're walking you'll
remember more words than if you do it
sitting still so I needed to lose some
weight anyways and I had a ton of
reading and a ton of study and I needed
to do so I did all of that on the
treadmill in the school gym and so like
I just hop on the treadmill going like
literally two miles an hour
like super slow but just walk for like
five or six hours a day like at a level
that it's not even exercise like two
miles an hour is super super slow but
it's like I'm gonna spend six hours a
day reading sitting on my ass or I'm
gonna do it walking at a very meandering
pace and I went from like 262 190 in
like four months um
which like I've never had any anything
like even bordering on that level of
success before and like I like I I have
tried the dietary strategies I was using
at that time again and it hasn't worked
nearly as well but like you were saying
like I'm the type of guy that when I go
into a deficit my neat just goes to zero
immediately like I'm capable of just
involuntarily being as still as a corpse
like that's just what my body does but
then when I had like an entire schedule
built around just very very low level
activity constantly everything works
super super great I'm the same way
personally some people I have worked
with and I want a caveat because I don't
act like you know but it's it's the only
thing but you know some work better when
they have like a burst of really intense
energy training and and and higher
cardiovascular demand even an aerobic
state I get it I totally understand but
for me the moment you take my food away
I've become a grumpy person and I just
want to lay on the couch so I don't move
and I don't want to move and I also have
a lot of periods of times in which that
I naturally don't move my natural step
intake for some weeks could be as high
as 3,000 maybe 4 because I'm reading all
day I'm writing all day like even going
out and walking a dog and and walking to
the grocery store and cooking I cook for
myself I don't I don't buy anything you
know out foods or what have you but I
just don't move and I'm little so I have
my treadmill desk yeah I I don't do
anything crazy I'm not I'm not the
overtraining I'm not neurotic about it I
come downstairs and I read
some studies and I write some things
down while I'm walking on my treadmill
this and I always tell people if it
wasn't for that thing I would be a
heifer I would be just you'd have to
roll me through a door because I like to
eat and when I don't eat I don't move
and deficits and cuts are not easy for
me and you know what is that they always
say sometimes you usually become
obsessed with what is not easy for you
and this has definitely been the case
for for fat loss or at least any sort of
adaptation very cool thing about me when
I diet my neat
certainly does go down but I also
essentially become a lizard and so what
I mean by that is my last prep was in
the middle of summer
so it was like late July in North
Carolina which is not mild in terms of
temperature and I would go in the middle
of my workday I'd be in the lab and I'd
be I'd have like two sweatshirts on and
like two pairs of pants and I would
literally go out and lay on a bench in
the Sun like a lizard on a rock just
trying to accumulate heat because I was
so cold so like my NEET would tank but
then when I know I'm like really ready
it's when I can no longer thermoregulate
and I need to start sunning myself like
like a reptile now we've talked about
metabolic adaptation and that kind of
naturally segues into the topic of after
you achieve the weight loss goal what do
you do after and so a lot of people talk
about reverse dieting or recovery
dieting or just saying screw it we did
it go back to normal what do you usually
have people do after or what do you
generally recommend in your writing
after a weight loss goal is achieved
yeah and you know this is I want to make
very clear this this section or this
aspect of things not that all of it to
some degree it's still a in my opinion a
blossoming area and research to see you
know how long does it take for X to
return to a homeostasis or you know
normal and this any other so I'll caveat
it with a few things to say that from my
knowledge my personal knowledge and in
research I think we have some good
general ideas about
how hard things can be for people to
return back to like a homeostasis after
repeating it also seems to be that a lot
of that coincides with how aggressive
the deficit was and how long the deficit
time period was so one of the things
that I think people get kind of
frustrated with with my answer on this
is it really is one of those it depends
situations for me and so I'll kind of
give my personal and it and it is very
much my opinion based upon what I've
read my kind of personal opinion of
these things but it does vary if I have
an individual that's come to me from
excessive overtraining probably
borderlining are actually just very much
borderlining probably on anorexia or
orthorexia kind of behavior really low
body weights bad mineral vitamin
deficiencies this kind of thing how
would an individual like that refeed one
that does border on medical treatment it
borders on a registered dietician being
needed I'm not saying it doesn't so as a
registered dietician if you're really if
you're listening to this and you're
thinking about that what I'll say is
what I found from working with
registered dietitians at the same time
or from people who have reported back to
me generally speaking slower refeeding
paces seem to do better psychologically
and physically they really do the it
seems to be from what we see that that
introducing a couple hundred calories
and and allowing the body to regulate
both in sodium electrolytes
glycogen and you know carbohydrate
uptake all of these kinds of things
psychologically what what it can do and
take place um if there's some sort of
extreme level of deficit needs to take
place and I am one and I was give
another caveat in which that going into
say contest or diet prep I like to do
that really slowly on the way down and I
like to kind of make it to where
everything is only restricted as needed
it's stret etc so the individuals in my
opinion shouldn't necessarily fit this
need this is kind of for someone who if
you will got there by accident
etc I I think that that being kind of
slow and steady about it and staying in
a maintenance fed state for their new
body weight and what that new
maintenance bodyweight is for at least a
period of I say on this to be on the
safe side you're talking about three
months plus it's not even up to six
months there's a lot of debate and about
that there's some research that says
that certain hormone levels can have a
time to kind of stabilize from again
more extreme deficits you know and and
start and even quote actual starvation
but I think the longer the worse that
you've been to yourself it's a really
really basic way of saying it but the
worst that you've been yourself the
longer you need to be better to yourself
and and I think that's saying at a
weight maintenance stable level and
trying to give yourself your time to
recuperate is good however I don't think
and I don't believe unless you are at an
underfed state that you need to
participate in a lot of heavy
overfeeding I think it's just trying to
move your your maintenance and one of
the things that I recommend too is that
you can lower what your maintenance
needs are for that particular period of
time based upon movement just as we were
talking about that movement can be
associated we're trying to keep it bay
any sort of adaptation well movement is
also the same with and your maintenance
is different every single day so if
you're having a hard time with repeating
or or getting up to your new calorie
levels or you're nervous about it or
you're having any sort of anticipation
issues with that slow you're moving down
you don't have to train as much you
don't have to move as much your steps
can be a little bit lower the activity
you do needs to be lower which means
your actual caloric need will be lower
and it can kind of in my opinion breeze
that gap and make individuals who are a
little bit nervous about losing the body
fat that they've lost or who are
psychologically uncomfortable about it
it makes them have that space right and
so then you can see okay well I met I
met weight maintenance I'm eating for my
needs at say 1600 or 1800 or for a male
or individual 2200 and that's on the
2500 it's on the lower end depending on
size and weight and things like that but
it can be that low and especially if
you're not really moving and you're just
doing maybe a few maintenance one or two
body full-body workouts or something
like that what you can do after that is
you can be stable and then you can go
okay let me
see how I can ramp it up and not
everybody wants more right not everybody
wants to eat more move more burn more
some people just want it to be
predictable and I think that that's
missed a lot I think that that's not
seen often that sometimes individuals
they don't necessarily want to burn as
much as they can possibly burn so they
can eat as much as they can possibly eat
I think sometimes people just want it to
be predictable and they don't want to be
scared about what's going to happen at
them because they don't understand so
what I try to do is I try to you know
facilitate that I'm like okay your
weights table everything seems to be
looking good you're fed this is what
your movement is is this level maybe now
we can see what ramping that up is and
how you feel and like take it to the
next place right you know because I have
different metabolic maintenances yeah I
can be at maintenance at 2,000 calories
or I can be at maintenance at 2,400
calories depending on how I train how I
move how I eat it's it's it never is the
same it's changing it's not static so um
in the in that aspect of refeeding you
know I look at the psychology of the
individual and what it is they kind of
need and that's the more kind of extreme
case if you will and it it seems that
the longer time you give you know I've
seen some studies III think that it's
I've seen some that have done six months
or more for certain levels to return
back to normal
I believe in thyroid and and and and
leptin there's one in particular that I
remember seeing but you know that's
that's kind of in my opinion the more
extreme if you've been so we'll jump to
the other side if you've been you know
any sort of cyclic dieting if if you've
been doing somewhat general deficits but
it's not been in any sort of extreme
deficits and you're just kind of going
in and out of dieting breaks I think
that people have gotten a little bit out
of control with refeeding and Diet
Breaking and they take it kind of too
far and they they're undoing deficit
work that they're achieving so yeah I
like to you'll see somebody who's like a
male and it's like yeah I'm dieting from
like 32 percent body fat to 27 and I
need to have like a 2 week diet break
every day every month and it's like ya
know you don't ya exactly just lose the
way it's fine it swung too far right I
feel personally attacked right no I'm
saying like there
no reason to double the time line if
you're not going to have a you know
thousand calorie a day deficit you get
down to like 4% body fat it's like you'd
be much happier and it'd be much more
expeditious to just apply a moderate
deficit and get where you're going you
know I completely agree with you 100% I
think it's swung too far in the other
direction in some again in some
subsections of what we're talking about
with this you know I see some I see some
groups or whatnot that I get added to or
something in the groups or literally
about feeding themselves back to
metabolic health and these men and women
are eating and insane they're just
getting fatter for the sake of getting
fatter and just gaining body fat for the
sake of body fat in the name of trying
to quote-unquote reset their metabolic
health because somehow their wires got
crossed and I think that that's what
they need to do so you know generally
speaking the the amount of weight
rebound
it's a good measure it is it's a good
measure of kind of seeing how what your
space is and I always kind of say which
is great about you know kind of using
yourself as a lab rat or control you
know be weight stable be weight you know
maintenance weight stable before going
into a deficit if you you know can can
handle something like that diet down and
see kind of what's your initial body
weight losses in those first two weeks
because the majority of that is going to
come back that's what that's gonna be
your comeback weight you know and
everything else that kind of happens
after that is going to be you know
mostly pure loss and then assume that
that comeback work it's gonna happen
ensure there's always variances for you
know tortillas and margaritas and and
being you know in a really high fed
overfed state and and that's gonna give
bounces but you can kind of look at you
even though the weight can lie and even
though the scale can kind of be be a
thing the weight is is a good measure to
kind of watch the trends and what's
going on and seeing how how much you're
bouncing and how much you're doing
things in that kind of a regard so um
but you know I feel attacked because
Greg knows I eat tacos every day that
tortilla cheap shot is really
uncalled-for
well I do I'm in it to be a low blow
sorry yeah yeah so I I do actually have
a real question okay
what what does the data from like the
research on the National Weight Control
Registry show because it's like those
people have lost a ton of weight and
have kept it off for I forget what the
criterion is but like a pretty long
period of time so like hormonal II
metabolically do they look like people
whose bodies are trying to get back to
their original weight still or do they
look more like people who never had to
lose all that weight to begin with let's
hope so I'm kind of thinking here like
like like how is the game different for
someone who you know gets down to
probably unhealthy low levels of body
fat and then their body's trying to get
back to you know general health versus
someone who is like forty five percent
body fat and then they cut to 15 and
then they've been there for a couple
years like well I think to be perfectly
honest with you I've never been
completely comfortable with all the data
that we have in that regard because I
think there's so many variables and
factors that data did I rarely see all
of them taken into account at the exact
same time and I hate to be like a
stickler but you know if you're looking
if you're trying to when I'm trying to
track god and say something like this is
a little I don't know if it's a little
overshooting my my scope but if you're
if you're trying to track whether or not
someone's at a healthy weight
maintenance at like whether or not that
it's they're metabolically healthy it's
a very complicated thing to say in the
first place am I in my personal opinion
because what makes someone metabolically
healthy is in my opinion going to be
okay no abnormal thyroid levels no
abnormal left and our Grenland levels
that or at least that that that seemed
to be outside of the scope of like
normal resting energy expenditure is
relatively you know normal or expected
for their body weight no signs are
noticeable signs of any sort of
nutritional deficiencies you know me
that skin elasticity hair basically
nothing no in women no in a manner eeeh
I mean men no libido problems or I guess
that could be women too but um that's
the kind of common to that lined up
together so let's say all those things
aren't there right those are the things
that you'd have to judge to not be there
um and in order for me to think that
you're kind of consider and I I guess
I'd like to ask Eric if he feels the
same that that we're kind of on the same
page but to me that kind of says you're
somewhat quote-unquote metabolic no no
bone issues no issues with osteoporosis
or any sort of bone mass loss you know
nothing that really says no CNS stress
issues maybe even though depression or
anxiety issues due to nutritional
deficiency I mean there's a lot of
factors for me to say like you're in a
space of metabolic healthiness from any
sort of long period of deficits I don't
know if that's kind of those are some of
the things that would fit in my criteria
of that what I would say is that the my
criteria of what looks healthy to make
quote those are some of the things that
would fit in my criteria no I think one
thing that's kind of related to that
something I often think about when I
look at these papers that show like you
know the presence of being in that kind
of metabolically adapted state is
there's all these physiological
parameters measured in it and the you
know the traditional research framework
or kind of state of mind is well here's
how they were before the weight loss are
there numbers after weight loss yeah
significantly different and when it
comes to things like you know total
energy expenditure or leptin levels like
yeah they probably should be lower than
they used to be because that's how a
weight loss works like I mean you know
people that have a lot of adiposity tend
to have a high resting metabolic rate
and a whole bunch of leptin yeah um so
like I think another thing to keep in
mind when you look at data relative to
right like relative yeah relative to are
they smelling too - yeah so yeah the
question is like when you're in that
post weight loss state not are you lower
than you used to be but are you
abnormally low outside of a reference
yeah that's what the the data or the
criteria I would use is what are their
levels like what are the resting do they
fit into a normal you know do they fit
into a normal for what somebody else at
that size who had not gone through
weight loss went you know so resting
energy expenditure for someone who has
gone through that weight stable are they
the same as someone who has not gone
through you know significant fat loss
how much does everything else line up
that's when I would I would feel
comfortable saying yeah relatively
metabolically similar to someone who has
not gone through those things and I'd
are my particulars and I do not know
there's particular like even just
looking like obviously I couldn't help
myself would start to Google um and I'm
and I'm on there and I'm just looking at
some of the the studies that they have
but nothing everything that I see with
the studies that I see is you know you
have like the Biggest Loser study or you
have studies about that are looking at
alterations and resting integer
expenditure or and and for the ones that
I find more interesting or what are the
ones that go below a normal baseline so
what are the ones in which that it's
like okay yeah you lose a certain amount
of resting energy expenditure or
metabolic level or rate being higher
because you've lost body fat sure you're
smaller you know that's gonna happen and
as Eric said leptin will you know be
lower or what have you is your Greenland
still raise right like is that is that
is that raised higher than an individual
who never diet it down before we have
seen that I have you know we have seen
some studies that that point to that but
you know the it's it also I will say
that in a lot of the studies that point
to that it's not all of them so then
what are those factors because as a
group it might be some experience that
some do not you know some will
experience elevated renlund levels I
even read a study that was talking about
elevated gremlin levels in couples who
have a fight or who don't get along as
much they have more elevated gremlin
levels after eating than those who do
get along and don't fight and and and so
post eating they did like this test
where they they
them they had them eat they had them you
know kind of have a conversation about
something that was somewhat difficult
for them to discuss and they measured
the levels now these are you know small
little statistic changes or what have
you but my point is is that gremlin is
sensitive from things other than just
say a caloric deficit so if you look at
what makes someone in a metabolic
healthy rate have higher greenland
levels after a long period time of a
deficit do everybody have that well if
they don't then what makes the
individuals not and that's kind of where
my more curiosity is you know like if
they do a research of people that have
these levels and they're still higher
post episode but some are not what's the
other variable or factor in that so I
guess what I was trying to say by the
answer my question that I said so
extremely poorly obviously was what rate
someone is metabolic healthy is going to
be complicated in my opinion and the
baseline is going to be compared to
people that seem to have had no issue
with any sort of weight loss period or
any sort of noticeable weight loss that
they've been somewhat relatively weight
stable their entire lives but then if
I'm perfectly honest with you and I
start to get OC and sound kind of crazy
I would also wonder how many of them
have psychological or physiological
factors from always staying weight
stable and if there's an other
individuals had other variations and
issues from not being able to maintain
weight stableness ranging from
depression to trauma so you name it so I
start to get I guess you can tell I
start to get to combing through the
variables yeah I mean I can tell you
from from what we see in the kind of
longer-term studies there there are at
least characteristics we can associate
with people who are more successful in
maintaining their weight loss those
usually tend to be high energy flux so
that they maintain high energy
expenditure after the weight loss the
other one is diligent tracking both of
body weight and food intake there is
that whole there's that scale study that
- that people who checked and watched
their scale weight every day you know
had post usually utilizing weight loss
had better weight maintenance than
individuals who did not
so the outer side out of mine asked for
things hi low-grade activity I've seen
that yeah there's a lot of variables to
what makes weight maintenance successful
post yeah I was going to say for me like
you know there's the the practical
aspect which is people who are good at
this what do they do and so we kind of
are starting to see some of those
answers come out now the other question
from a physiological perspective is can
we get somebody can we kind of guide
them back to a normal physiological
state after weight loss maybe even close
to where they were before they lost the
weight can we get them there without
substantial fat regain and that's a
question that it interests me a great
deal if anyone's at the ISSN conference
this year we should have a poster up
about this I don't know if I'm allowed
to spoil those results yet but it's
something that keeps me up at night the
question of how do we get someone fully
recovered from an extreme diet when it
comes to physiological variables hormone
levels things of that nature how can we
get them there without a really
significant fat regain I'm not sure if I
have a good answer yet I have some
suspicions but it's a work in progress
for my personal anecdotal experiences
slow and steady and education them
understanding I mean just personal
anecdote going from extremes slow and
steady
coming out of it them understanding
exactly what's happening while it's
happening
and really controlling the factors and
variables of movement and and the
awareness of all those things combining
together and maybe that's an
oversimplification of it for some
individuals but it and and of course I
think that it should be noted how much
fat loss you're really talking about and
I think that there's something
individuals listening this keeping in
mind some are thinking about address
that they want to fit into it a reunion
where as other individuals are thinking
about
contest dieting for stage and I think
they're very different worlds obviously
right
now Lee a question we like to ask people
especially the more evidence-based kind
of individuals that work with clients is
there anything that you do in your own
training and nutrition or something that
you have clients do that kind of goes
against the grain in the evidence-based
community so basically is there anything
you do that there's not a substantial
amount of evidence to support but but
you feel really strongly about it um I
think that the I think the walking and
in generally speaking keeping low stress
in general during a deficit period for
physique especially is is kind of
because a lot of the research I see
people throw out is look at how much
this high aerobic or cardiovascular
training exercise led to greater results
etc I see us and I see a lot of people
in an evidence-based industry trying to
kind of ramp up fat loss with aggressive
training and I've always kind of been I
like to keep my aggressive training and
my really pushing the limits of what
someone can do both in conditioning and
muscle gain and composition changes I
really like to push that in maintenance
or in in a slight you know even surplus
of needs so I don't find a lot of people
that support that and a lot of the books
that come out about you know metabolic
excellence and efficiency and things
like that they don't really tell that as
much so I think that that goes against
it and and I and I do think that what we
were just talking about in the aspect of
kind of slow and steady with certain
individuals of refeeding I don't really
know if it necessarily goes against
anything but I know that I'm railed up
against it because often time you know
patience and and to some degree what
could we say a physical need to actually
just feed and wanting to get back to
homeostasis as quickly as possible I
don't I don't know how much of that is
what can we feed really fast and just
make ourselves feel better versus using
ourselves up and there
there's there's really not a lot of
literature and slow refeeding there's
there's a little bit of an anorexia and
starvation studies about that but even
with that they usually even with the
refeeding they usually end up over
feeding and going through periods of
overfeeding phases depending on just
because someone is an erection or vaisya
doesn't mean they're necessarily weird
low body weight as well so that's so
trying to dive through and mix the the
research on that is really complicated
so yeah long-winded answer but I would
say kind of low grade intensity and
training during phases of fat loss and
doing only what you have to do and maybe
the kind of for certain individuals
slower refeeding but I will say that the
majority of the time what I say is just
eat so that's that's that's just a small
very small subsection of it because the
majority of people is like oh just eat
or some individuals is no you don't need
to even yet at all like keep going if
you can yeah now a while back Greg and I
kind of got together we surveyed the
landscape of the fitness industry and we
had noticed that no one had made a
podcast yet so we made one oh yeah and I
saw on your website that you also have a
podcast in the works is so kind of a
two-part question why and also are you
familiar with the term intellectual
property sure well I mean so so honestly
what what Eric is fishing for here is
he's wondering if we were your main
inspiration or your only inspiration
well as as Peter Cetera would say you
were the meaning in my life you're the
inspiration and I think that that
applies to both of you equally and I
mean that from the bottom of my heart
and I take Chicago and Peter Cetera very
seriously so there's that and I I really
don't have any original ideas guys I
don't have a mind of my own ultimately
and when I saw that you were doing a
podcast I had to Google what it was even
though I had done one years ago that's
not relevant but I had to Google what it
was I had to figure out the ins and outs
of it and stuff
like that and it just seemed really
fascinating to me so it's like radio but
there is no barrier to entry it it's so
groundbreaking it's really what the
Internet's about to be perfectly honest
with you so what's your angle here
what's your podcast gonna be about well
mine is fun to be honest with you so
much more groundbreaking than yours is
the the premise of my podcast is I I add
this joke and that came about with the
whole one let me google that for you I
don't know if anyone listening or you
guys have ever seen let me google that
for you where you obnoxiously type
something and to Google through this
thing and send it to somebody and it
says let me google that for you and
there's also kind of a common dickish
phrase as well that's I'll just leave
this right here um and someone who's
kind of smarming Lee and obnoxiously
trying to explain what's right and how
they're wrong and they're just gonna
leave this right here for them to look
at and so the combination of those kinds
of things festered and brewed in my
brain and I wanted the ability to to
kind of not be hindered and talk on a
lot of topics so I came up with the
podcast so I'll just leave this right
here and essentially it's going to try
to be tried to be my tactful and at
times you know evidence-based opinions
or thoughts on calming Lee difficult and
argumentative topics and sometimes it
also be other people's answers and my
way of passing it around was if
something comes up they'll also be an
article form too I'll just put a little
link and I'll just say well I'll just
I'll just leave this right here so if
someone's talking about X and and I
happen to have talked about it I'll just
I'll just leave it right there and and
and leave it on someone's link and also
everybody can just listen to it in
general but I was gonna have guests as
well every once in a while to come on
and they can leave something right there
and I just thought it'd be fun I thought
it'd be fun and I thought it'd be
something a little different and yeah
there will definitely be fitness and and
nutrition based conversations and stuff
like that around things but there also
be other things like for example my
personal and actually
is what I really should have said when
you're talking about what I believe in
that hasn't been proven but my belief
that people that don't return the
shopping carts are well not good people
and that they're also probably higher in
BMI I'm just throwing it out there I am
so I'm I'm trying to find funding for
this research and careful because
there's a lot of like social media sites
that are cracking down on hate speech
and you were getting very very close I
know I'm really close I know I should
probably I should probably dye it down
this is where you know this is this is
where the true through that comes out
and we've been talking for a bit and
while all of my barriers are down so
you're getting the real truth of me and
and yeah I I have strong feelings about
this and I'm I'm sorry I'm not gonna
apologize for just not we just you said
I'm sorry you know what I am apparently
Canadian so I've she was apologizing for
the fact that she's not going to
apologize I thought I thought that was
pretty kind of thing but you know yeah
so that's that's that's where the
important research really is not not any
of this yeah that's where I'm gonna put
my real focus very cool so aside from
the podcast is there anything else we
should be keeping an eye out for in the
near future um generally speaking I'm
trying to be a better contributor again
into the realm of articles and things
being written I'm gonna have so I read
this thing a series on research or an
article that I've read that I'm gonna be
putting up on my blog not behind a
paywall
um there'll be some behind a paywall for
my members but the majority of them will
not be behind a paywall and actually in
generally trying to get myself not
behind a paywall so much so that that I
can kind of be a better contributor in
that regard and so my website it's it Li
Paul comfrey stuff to see on my website
and everything points there and if I and
if you can't find something that I'm
supposed to do that's my fault
so yeah just that and can I make a
suggestion when it comes to the paywall
stuff yes you actually
different different approach you could
take that I've been using so I've done a
lot of academic research and I've worked
out this cool scenario where I do though
I do all the work and it goes behind a
paywall but I don't make any money from
it which is a very very cool model that
you might consider implementing if you
just made a paywall but gave away all of
the money and sometimes you have to pay
a few thousand dollars to have access to
put your things down okay all right so
it's a different model that kind of runs
parallel to yours
yeah I could consider it's very cool
very legal inexplicably legal to be
honest I'm I'm gonna really I'm gonna
look into that thanks so much right it's
something that all of the Harvard
scientists are doing well if they're
doing it all of your favorite people
you've seen on the dr. Oz Show actually
probably not many I want to say I know I
don't know a honest all right so we've
got those things coming up on the
horizon now if people want to stay in
touch with Lee and they want to see what
you're up to and connect with you where
can they find you on the Internet leave
he'll calm my facebook asleep hill I
really apparently left my name so it's
just leap hill is everything I will be
doing some speaking gigs I'm gonna be
speaking at evolve in Canada this in
September and I'm gonna be speaking in
Seattle in August so those those two
things are coming up so if you in
Seattle or you're in Edmonton during
those times love to see you that'd be
great
and yeah that's that's pretty much it
trying to be low on the pluggy
I do have a book coming out but it's not
for a very very long time so that that
can wait but I hope that you enjoyed the
thing see it's never - yeah yeah I'm
doing it I'm doing an audible and major
market and Kindle release so it's major
major market release if fat-loss
troubleshoot and I've never done it
before I've always been a book base I'm
really excited and it's going to be in
2020 so it's it I'm really excited about
it it's I feel it's the best stuff I've
ever written
so I'm I can't wait till it's till it's
out there into the world so really
excited about that that's awesome
congratulations yeah that's that's super
cool could Congrats on getting that
thank you thank you very much I'm really
excited about it we've got a thing on
the podcast if you hang on for like over
an hour we start to become sincere well
then then I feel I feel really honestly
I feel touched and blessed by that
because not not to get to to ask Issy
but but really brilliant both brilliant
minds and and I was I'm not usually
nervous or anticipatory that's word
before coming on these kinds of things
but I was little I was little I wanted
to I wanted to do justice because it's I
know it's gonna be a great podcast and
there's only been a few so far but of
what I've heard is already great and I
know it's going to be great in the
future and to be a part of it I'm
actually really I'm really happy to be a
part of it well now that you've come on
I hope you can see that there was
nothing to be worried about because
generally what ends up happening is that
I wind up as the but of all of the jokes
yeah he's kind of mean to you Greg he's
a little that's crazy so I I've learned
my lesson because it's the one that
edits the audio and so anytime I try to
slip in a good joke where he's the butt
of it just cuts it out like a snowflake
that's amazing yeah he has the power
dude yeah I'd really he's got an audio
debater so I boy me Oh can't can't take
the heat no I just
when I say funny things they're
light-hearted you practice hate speech
and I have to leave that on the cutting
room floor
so that we don't get D platformed yes
that's it's and he's serving some good
points I'm gonna be honest and you just
called him a beta soy boy so yeah but I
was being I was being sarcastic yes sir
of course of course
yes tell that to Zuckerberg yeah all
right well at least thank you so much
for coming on we really enjoyed talking
to you we hope that maybe someday you'll
consider our dinner invitation you can
bring
whoever you want it's not like a super
selective thing but thanks so much for
coming on we really appreciate it thank
you so much for having me really thank
you thanks for listening to the stronger
by science podcast now Greg and I are
not experts in medicine or health or
really anything else for that matter so
before you make any changes to your diet
and exercise habits make sure you check
with a doctor or another healthcare
professional if you enjoyed this podcast
and you'd like to support it
visit stronger by science comm to check
out the products and services that we
offer thanks for listening and we'll see
you next time
[Music]
[Music]